Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei Forschergeist. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und hier ist die 13. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie rund um wissenschaftliche Themen. Organisation von Wissenschaft, Details von Wissenschaft, Erkenntnisse der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit. Und wir wollen auch immer wieder auf Dinge blicken, die relevant sind für die eigene wissenschaftliche Arbeit und wie man seine eigene Arbeit am besten organisieren kann und natürlich auch finanzieren kann. Und das ist heute der Fokus. Wir wollen über Förderungen sprechen, und zwar ganz konkret über die Förderungsmöglichkeiten für Wissenschaft in den EU-Programmen. Und dazu begrüße ich Claudia Eggert, schönen guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag Herr Pritlove.
Sie sind Leiterin einer sogenannten Kooperationsstelle der EU oder für die EU, der Wissenschaftsorganisationen. Richtig aufgesagt?
Ja, Sie haben das ohne Stolperer aussprechen können.
Wobei ich korrigieren muss, ich leite das Brüsseler Büro der KOWI, also der Kooperationsstelle EU der deutschen Wissenschaftsorganisationen. Wir haben aber zwei Standorte. Eine Kollegin, die das Bonner Büro leitet und dann einen Gesamtleiter. Also etwas heruntergenommen die Verantwortung.
Hurra.
Okay, aber es gibt da so eine Achse zwischen Deutschland und Brüssel, die da so auf gleicher Augenhöhe miteinander kommunizieren?
Bevor wir vielleicht da auf die Details kommen, würde mich natürlich nochmal interessieren, wie sind Sie denn da überhaupt hingeraten? Also was sind Ihre eigenen Verbindungen mit der Wissenschaft gewesen?
Mhmh.
Ja eine gute Frage, wie vielleicht einige, die meine Profession dann im Wissenschaftsmanagement gelandet zu sein teilen, dass ich eigentlich mal gestartet bin selber als Wissenschaftlerin. Als sogar recht vielversprechende Biotechnologin bin ich sogar mal hier an der TU Berlin gestartet. Und mich hat dann gerade in den Bereich Europa geführt, eine Stipendienzeit, die ja auch viele Wissenschaftler auch teilen in den USA, war dort als Postdoc und habe vielleicht da erst mal den ersten Spaß in der Wissenschaft bekommen. Bin zurück gekommen nach Deutschland und wollte diesen Esprit, den viele auffangen, die glaube ich in den USA forschen, dort sehr internationale Umfelder kennenlernen, nach Deutschland transportieren und habe dann relativ schnell gemerkt, dass das deutsche Wissenschaftssystem zu der Zeit noch ziemlich zäh war und mein ganzer Schwung in meinem eigenen Wissenschaftsgebiet da jetzt bis zum Lebensende da Tag und Nacht zu forschen, alle Freunde zu verlieren und vielleicht noch 10-20 Publikationen jedes Jahr anzuhäufen, hat mich irgendwie so ein bisschen ausgebremst.
Wann war das?
Das war so Ende der 90er Jahre. Ich bin also so 15 Jahre jetzt auf der anderen Seite, mit der Motivation eigentlich in dem System von der anderen Seite zu wirken und Wissenschaftlern, die diesen Spaß auch in Deutschland weiter haben und gerade junge Wissenschaftler so zu unterstützen, dass sie eben Forschung machen können und auch die Rahmenbedingungen etwas zu verbessern. Und ich bin dann gewechselt, das war in der Uni Jena, wo mein Wissenschaftsgebiet noch zur Habilitation stark vertreten war, bin dort gewechselt ins Wissenschaftsmanagement mit dem Fokus EU. Dort vor Ort Forscher regionale, die Forschungsrahmenprogramme zu bringen. Dann bin ich in eine etwas verantwortungsvollere Position an der Hochschule gewachsen. War Dezernentin, habe dort ein Servicezentrum aufgebaut für Forschung und Transfer.
Habe also auch den Blick werfen müssen auf nationale Programme, auf den Technologietransfer, Existenzgründung, das sind alles Themen, wenn wir jetzt übers Forschungsrahmenprogramm sprechen das europäische, alles Aspekte sind.
Und bin dann über Stationen, über den Projektträger, der für das BMBF die Gremienarbeit macht in meinem eigenen Fachgebiet, Biotechnologie, Lebenswissenschaften und der Medizin, immer an den europäischen Rahmenprogrammen als Hauptfokus weiter gegangen und jetzt seit fünf Jahren leite ich das Brüsseler Büro der KOWI. Die sozusagen als Gegenstück zu den nationalen Unterstützern des BMBF, des Bundesministeriums für Bildung und Forschung, Wissenschaftler unterstützt, in den Forschungsrahmenprogrammen aktiv zu sein und erfolgreich.
Und wer ist der Träger des KOWI? Gibt es da einen?
Ja gute Frage. Das ist – zum Glück gibt es einen - das ist ein illustrer Verein, der allen voran die DFG als unser Financier beinhaltet, aber auch die Hochschulenrektorenkonferenz und alle großen Wissenschaftsorganisationen des deutschen Wissenschaftssystems. Also Max-Planck, die Max-Planck-Gesellschaft, die Leibniz-Gemeinschaft, Helmholtz, aber auch den Stifterverband, für den Sie ja hier heute auch stehen und die AIF, also eigentlich bildet das ab, alles was wir als KOWI, als Mandat haben, nämlich die sozusagen die freie Wissenschaft zu repräsentieren.
AIF ist die Arbeitsgemeinschaft industrieller Forschungsvereinigungen?
Ja.
Okay. Also quasi alle Wissenschaftsorgan.. also alle relevanten Wissenschaftsorganisationen Deutschlands haben sich da zusammengetan und diese Kooperationsstelle eingerichtet, damit sie wirken kann.
Genau, damit sie wirken kann. Und wir gerade nächste Woche in Berlin das 25 jährige Bestehen der KOWI, also Sie können sich vorstellen, das ist schon vor einer ganzen Weile passiert. Nach und nach kamen noch Trägervereinsmitglieder dazu, aber der Fokus, der Kern, der jetzt auch eigentlich unsere Services abruft, weil die primär sich an Wissenschaftler richten, den gab es eben schon seit langer Zeit.
Ja, Forschungsförderung. Also hier geht es jetzt sozusagen explizit um finanzielle Ausstattung von wissenschaftlichen Projekte und Wissenschaftlern aus EU-Geldern, sehe ich das richtig?
Genau.
Und seit wann gibt es das so überhaupt? Also am Anfang war ja die EU noch lange Zeit in ihrer industriellen Förderungstradition.
Kohle und Stahl.
Kohle und Stahl genau. Und wann fing das an, sich so breiter aufzustellen?
Ja, wir gucken zurück, das kaschiert jetzt dieser eigentlich für die Steuerzahler gedachte neue Name des letzten Rahmenprogrammes, Horizon2020, das ist das aktuelle Programm, auf das Wissenschaftler seit 1,5 Jahren zugreifen können. Das kaschiert eigentlich die Nummerierung, die bis dahin vorgeherrscht hat, nämlich das ist das achte Forschungsrahmenprogramm. Das heißt wir können also rückwärts zählen. Es gab mal ein erstes, das ist, wenn ich mich nicht irre, 1984 gewesen. Damals war die Laufzeit der Programme noch kürzer. Jetzt das Horizon 2020 läuft also bis 2020 sieben Jahre. Und es hat begonnen eben aus einer doch Orientierung an der Wirtschaftsförderung. Es gab kleinere Projekte und vor allen Dingen das Ziel, die Wirtschaft und die europäischen Politiken zu unterstützen. Wenn wir das jetzt sukzessive über die Laufzeiten der Programme sehen, dann stellt man erst mal erfreulicherweise aus Wissenschaftlersicht fest, dass es die Budgets und damit auch die Bedeutung dieser Forschungsrahmenprogramme stark zugenommen haben.
Das ist jetzt auch bei aller, vielleicht kommen wir noch darauf zu sprechen, Herausforderung, die mit einer Beteiligung an diesem Rahmenprogramm verbunden ist, für die meisten auch ein Motivationsfaktor, wenn man nur auf der monetären Seite schaut, dass diese Rahmenprogramme, also in den letzten Programmperioden deutliche Zuwächse erfahren haben. Das ist gerade, wenn wir über ein europäisches Programm schauen, deshalb auch interessant, dass in vielen Mitgliedsstaaten, wo die nationale Forschungsförderung zurückgefahren wird, gerade als Reaktion auch auf die Wirtschaftskrise, ist das keine Selbstverständlichkeit. Was man feststellen kann in der Programmierung dieser Forschungsrahmenprogramme, ist, dass die EU immer mehr zu einer auch politisch strukturierenden Anforderungen an diese Rahmenprogramme kam. Am Anfang 1./2./3. bis zum 5., ich glaube das war das Rahmenprogramm, wo ich dann eingestiegen bin, rund um das Jahr 2000, waren das Projektförderungen mit verschiedenen inhaltlichen Themen, Nachwuchsförderung.
Aber wir sehen jetzt in die letzten Rahmenprogramme und auch in diesem Horizon 2020 auch Elemente, die dazu beitragen sollen, den europäischen Forschungsraum, also dieses politische Ziel, zu erreichen. Also koordinierende Projektförderungen, sowohl im Hinblick auf nationale Forschungsmittel, die koordiniert zu größeren europäischen Programmelementen noch beitragen sollen, aber auch koordinierend im Hinblick auf eine höhere Einbeziehung der Industrie und um deren Gelder koordiniert für europäische Projektinitiativen verfügbar zu machen.
Das heißt ja die einzelnen Rahmenprogramme sind, im Wesentlichen könnte man auch davon sprechen, es gibt halt einfach immer ein Forschungsrahmenprogramm ein aktuelles, aber die Leitlinien dafür und damit auch die verbundenen Etats enden dann erst mal zu einem Zeitpunkt und müssen dann eben politisch neu ausgehandelt werden?
Ja genau.
Und dadurch haben sich dann über die Zeit auch die Prioritäten und Schwerpunkte verlagert? Was würden Sie sagen, wie sie sich verlagert haben? Wo fing das an und was sind jetzt die .. oder haben sie sich überhaupt verändert? Also das ist jetzt eine Unterstellung von mir. Irgendwas verändert sich ja immer. Wie hat sich das so bewegt?
Ja erst mal müsste man sagen, das ist jetzt gerade aktuell, dass es natürlich ein Einfluss ist immer der gesamtpolitische Rahmen, der jetzt mit dem Start des letzten Rahmenprogrammes ganz stark durch die Wirtschaftskrise beeinflusst wurde. Das heißt diese Rahmenprogramme werden verhandelt zwischen den drei Institutionen. Die Kommission macht einen Vorschlag klassischerweise bei diesen auch Gesetzgebungsverfahren, dem auch das Rahmenprogramm unterliegt. Daneben die Mitgliedsstaaten und das Parlamentsstellung. Und gerade das Parlament drängte intensiv darauf, zu sagen, was soll denn der Steuerzahler davon haben, dass hier in Forschung investiert wird. Und sie sehen das, dass die Forschungskommissarin, die in der letzten Periode verantwortlich war für die Gestaltung dieses Horizon2020 reagiert hat, indem die Innovationsteile, die in anderen Programmen, in anderen europäischen Töpfen existierten, die wurden mit diesem Rahmenprogramm verschmolzen. Das ist jetzt das erste, was nicht nur die Forschung und Entwicklung, sondern auch bis in den Bereich Innovation reinragt und das sind alles Reaktionen auf das politische Umfeld.
Was sich dann verändert hat, dass dann eben diese strukturierenden Initiativen, da gibt es so was wie Joint Programming Initiativen. Das heißt gemeinsame Forschungsplanung der Mitgliedsstaaten und deren nationalen Geldern, die koordiniert in größeren europäischen Zusammenhängen das gleiche machen sollen. So dass größere Dinge existieren und nicht jedes Mitgliedsland eigentlich zu ähnlichen Themen mit kleinen, unbedeutenderen Budgets vor sich hin werkeln lässt und die Hebelwirkung eigentlich nicht so groß ist. Was mit dem letzten Rahmenprogramm noch dazu kam, was sich verändert hat, ist, dass – ein schönes europäisches Wort – die ursprünglichen Rahmenprogramme die Vorgaben hatten, nach dem Subsidiaritätsprinzip nur zu fördern. Das heißt, es durfte europäisch nur das gemacht werden, was nicht auf nationaler Ebene laufen konnte. Schon relativ mühsam, aber wurde so umgesetzt.
Also europäische Verbünde war klar. Europäische Projekte mit vielen Partnern die gab es national nicht, also war das eigentlich das Instrument der Umsetzung. Und was mit dem vorletzten Rahmenprogramm dazukam, und das war eigentlich eine Sensation oder irgendwie auch ein Dammbruch, der in der Wissenschaft aber sehr gut ankam, ist die Schaffung des europäischen Forschungsrates. Wo auf einmal Einzelprojektförderungen, einzelne Forscher große Projektmittel für ihre Topideen, also echte Exzellenzforschung, bekommen konnten. Und dieser europäische Forschungsrat, der ist dann nochmal eine neue Entwicklung, die in den letzten Jahren dazu gekommen ist. Und wenn wir heute hier vielleicht mit unserer Zielgruppe Wissenschaftler am Ohr sprechen, dann ist das das Mittel, was eigentlich in der wissenschaftlichen Community gerade besonders gut angekommen ist.
Also der europäische Forschungsrat ist jetzt explizit ein Organ der EU? Also von der Europäischen Kommission?
Nein ist es nicht. Sondern es ist ein unabhängiges Gremium, eigentlich so was wie die DFG könnte man übersetzen für die deutsche Wissenschaftsszene, die deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft, die also Geld wissenschaftsnah an die Wissenschaftscommunity vergibt. Und so ist auch der europäische Forschungsrat ein eigener Förderkörper, der Mittel bekommt von der europäischen Kommission, die aber mehr oder weniger eigenständig verwaltet und auch von der Wissenschaft kontrolliert und mit eigenen Verfahren operieren kann.
Ich sehe gerade, das fällt in die Liste der Agenturen der europäischen Union. Also schon sozusagen eine EU-Initiative, aber dann nicht Organ im Sinne von teil- und weisungsbefugt, sondern es wird halt mal eingerichtet und lebt dann für sich selbst weiter.
Und das macht auch das attraktive aus, wenn Sie da gerade schauen, denn diese normalen Rahmenprogramme sind ja oft auch mit dem Vorurteil, ob jetzt berechtigt oder nicht können wir noch drüber diskutieren, behaftet, das alles bürokratisch ist, mit viel Red Tape verbunden. So dieser europäische Forschungsrat der kann sich eigene Regeln geben, eigene Verfahren und die sind deutlich schlanker. Wenn man Agentur hört, das ist noch eine weitere Neuerung, die wir jetzt gerade mit Horizon2020 sehen und die auch widerspiegelt, wie die europäische Kommission und ich rede jetzt eigentlich über die Generaldirektion Forschung und Innovation. Forschung und Innovation, die das Rahmenprogramm gestaltet, ist also wie ein Ministerium in der europäischen Kommission, wenn an das übersetzt, die haben jetzt begonnen mehr und mehr mit einer Art Projektträgerschaft zu arbeiten. Also das kennen wir aus Deutschland die Projektträger die PDLR, Projektträger Jülich, die für das Bundesministerium Mittel verwalten. Und die Kommission hat begonnen, solche Exekutivagenturen jetzt verstärkt mit der Projektabwicklung zu betrauen, um sich mehr und mehr eben politischen Gestalten zuzuwenden.
Also heißt das, dass der Forschungsrat dann auch tatsächlich für die Vergabe der Forschungsmittel und innerhalb dieses Rahmenprogrammes zuständig ist?
Ja genau.
Also das ist sozusagen dann auch die entscheidende Gruppe?
Ja das ist richtig ausgelagert. Das ist ein Budget von mehr als 9 Milliarden Euro jetzt für die gesamte Laufzeit, die dieser europäische Forschungsrat für eigene Programmlinien, Förderlinien verausgabt.
Und inwiefern ist jetzt mit diesem Rahmenprogramm da jetzt auch thematisch schon was vorgegeben oder ist das dann auch tatsächlich dann die eigene Entscheidung dieses Forschungsrates, dass dann festzulegen, was jetzt auch wirklich opportun sei, beforscht zu werden?
Ist auch nochmal eine gute Frage, das zu verstehen. Der Hauptteil des Rahmenprogramms, etwa 60% des Budgets, werden Top-Down mit vorgegebenen Themen umgesetzt, vergeben. Also man bewirbt sich als Wissenschaftler auf Themen, die im weitesten Sinne von der Kommission gesetzt sind, mit Einflussnahme durch verschiedene weitere Akteure. Aber der Forschungsrat ist wie die deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft, die vergibt Mittel und es gibt grob gesagt vier Förderlinien. Drei für Nachwuchswissenschaftler und eine für Advance Grantees, so was wie die europäischen Nobelpreisträger in spe, die sind aber thematisch offen werden die vergeben. Also jeder, der eine gute Idee hat, kann sich dort bewerben. Es gibt keine thematische Einschränkung. Alles was dieser Forschungsrat vorgegeben hat ist die Struktur, die Mittel werden vergeben für eine Nachwuchsgruppe mit so und so vielen Mitteln und auch in einer bestimmten Aufstellung von Mitarbeitern oder Geräten, die zu bestimmten Bedingungen beantragt werden können.
Aber alles andere ist frei. Und das ist eigentlich auch das, was so wunderbar ankommt in der Wissenschaftscommunity, denn dort haben eben auch Philosophen im weitesten Sinne Historiker, Geisteswissenschaftler ihren eigenen Platz, der sonst nicht so leicht zu finden ist. In dem doch eher anwendungsorientierten Forschungsrahmenprogramm.
Oder zumindest eine Chance sozusagen, diesen Platz einzunehmen.
Ja.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu den gesetzten Themen. Also wer setzt die? Ist mir jetzt nicht so ganz klar geworden.
Ja auch darüber könnten wir jetzt auch nochmal einen kleinen Exkurs einlegen.
Bitte dafür sind wir ja hier.
Wir als KOWI verwenden nicht geringen Teil unserer Zeit damit, auch in Seminaren zu erklären, wer wie Einfluss nimmt auf die Themensetzung. Im weitesten Sinne kann man es aber so beschreiben, dass sich im Vorfeld von diesem Horizon2020 der Entstehung hatte man sich darauf geeinigt, dass große gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen themenbestimmend sein sollen und da sind sieben definiert worden. Also Sie finden alles, wir haben vorhin gerade über Podcasts hier in dieser Reihe geschaut, da ist eigentlich vieles von dem, was Sie angerissen haben, wird thematisiert. Also es geht um ... Sie sind voll im Kern. Also die Energieforschung hat einen großen Teil in diesen gesellschaftlichen Herausforderungen. Medizin, der Bereich ICT, Umwelt, aber auch die Sozial- und Geisteswissenschaften in gewissem Sinne. Da geht es um die Security. Das ist ein großer Bereich und der wird jetzt über die Laufzeit von sieben Jahren, in jeweils zweijährigen thematischen Vorgaben, die sind zusammengefasst in Dokument, die WorkPrograms heißen.
Arbeitsprogramme, die werden von der Kommission vorgeschlagen, von den Mitgliedsstaaten kommentiert. Dann gibt es noch Technologieplattformen, also Akteure, Verbünde, die sich rund um diese großen Themen, die gesellschaftlichen Herausforderungen gruppieren und die Kommission bereichern mit Trends, Themen, die wichtig und in der nächsten Zeit, also top beforschbar sein sollen.
Sieben Themen waren das jetzt? Sieben große Themen?
Sieben große gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen.
Jetzt haben wir aber nur fünf irgendwie berührt.
Soll ich die alle nennen? Also es gibt noch Transport. Dann gibt es den Bereich Ernährung/Nahrung, im weitesten Sinne die Bioeconomy wird dort zusammengefasst.
Okay und das war es dann. Geisteswissenschaften haben dann sozusagen ihren eigenen Bereich?
Die haben einen eigenen Bereich genau.
Energie und Computer.
Und dann gibt es daneben einen eher noch industrienäheren Teil. Da sind die Schlüsseltechnologien zusammengefasst. Und da steckt nochmal im weitesten Sinne die Nanotechnologie drin, Biotechnologie und auch der Bereich ICT, der sich als Querschnitt durch das gesamte Rahmenprogramm zieht.
Wer hat diese Themenliste bestimmt? Also wer hat das ausgearbeitet?
Den großen Rahmen dieser Themen, die ich gerade genannt habe?
Ja.
Also wirklich fast alles abdecken, was man sich vorstellen kann, was beforscht werden müsste, aus europäischer Sicht, der wird verhandelt zu Beginn jedes Rahmenprogrammes. Da hat man also diesen großen Themenrahmen, den die Mitgliedsstaaten und auch das europäische Parlament absegnen. Das ist passiert vor dem Start von Horizon. Und die Umsetzung dieses großen Rahmenprogramms, Themen, die erfolgt in zweijährigen dann sehr spezifischen Ausschreibungen und dort werden Themen, das sind sogenannte Topics, definiert, wo es dann heißt, Alzheimer soll bekämpft werden mit folgenden Ansätzen, macht uns Vorschläge liebe Forscher. Und als Wissenschaftler, das ist das wichtigste dann eigentlich, zu verstehen, muss man sich diese Arbeitsprogramme besorgen, möglichst frühzeitig, vielleicht sogar durch Quellen wie unsere, bevor sie offiziell verkündet werden, und sich dann orientieren, ob man mit dem was man beforscht und Partnern, die man zusammenstellt oder vielleicht schon hat, dann einen Beitrag leistet, um diese Herausforderung zu lösen in Form eines Projekts.
Also diese großen Themen, also meine Frage war ja, wer setzt das fest? Also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, die Kommission gründet da einen Arbeitskreis und ist entsprechend wissenschaftlich beraten und dann wird das irgendwann mit dem Parlament und dem Rat irgendwie abgestimmt und dann ist das sozusagen erst mal so die Metageschichten.
Auf der großen Ebene genau.
Und diese sieben großen Metathemen sind sozusagen so die gesetzten Felder, die will man beforscht wissen, und da gehen wie viel nochmal rein? 60% des gesamten Budgets?
Ja in etwa.
Und das heißt, man kann dann als Wissenschaftler oder Wissenschaftlergruppe dahin gehen und sagen, hier Energieforschung mein Ding, irgendwie wir haben da eine prima Idee, wir machen da mal einen Projektantrag.
Wir schauen mal, das wäre das eine, dass man passiv schauen kann, es gibt also regelmäßig einmal im Jahr eine Ausschreibung in einem bestimmten Themengebiet, wo man dann als Wissenschaftler schaut oder durch uns oder andere Berater den Startschuss bekommt. Oft auch an den eigenen Einrichtungen informiert wird und sagt, jetzt gibt es eine Ausschreibung im Bereich Energie, wenn wir bei dem Thema bleiben wollen, und dann können Sie schauen, ob in dieser Ausschreibung, wo schon definierte Themen existieren, ob Sie da passfähig sind und sich wiederfinden. Die höhere Kunst beginnt dann da, zu verstehen, wenn Sie sich nicht wiederfinden oder wenn Sie noch Einfluss nehmen wollen auf die Themen, zu verstehen, wie die Übersetzung dieses großen Rahmens, der sieben Jahre Bestand hat in Form von Horizon2020, wie der übersetzt wird in diese zweijährigen Ausschreibungsthemen, also diese speziellen Themen, die dann tatsächlich zu Projekten führen.
Und da arbeitet dann die Kommission in Form von Referenten, Project Officern in der Kommission, wo es Spezialisten gibt für jedes dieser Themen und die konsultiert und befruchtet sich im Vorfeld von solchen Übersetzungen die Arbeitsprogrammen auf den verschiedensten Ebenen und da wird es dann interessant, wenn man wirklich aktiv sein Thema voranbringen möchte, dass man durch uns und auch durch andere beraten wird, welche Kanäle dazu führen, dass bestimmte Themen dann in diesen Ausschreibungen auftauchen.
Die Kommission macht das oder macht das dieser Forschungsrat?
Der Forschungsrat der hat seine 9 Milliarden und da geht es gar nicht ums Themensetzen, weil der sagt, so sind unsere Projekttypen, gebt uns einfach nur gute Ideen. Das ist themenoffen. Also wir nennen es Bottom-Up.
Okay. Also der Forschungsrat kümmert sich sozusagen nur um die themenoffenen Geschichten, die strukturell definiert sind und die Kommission verteilt die Gelder für die gesetzten Themen?
Für die gesetzten Themen und dann dürften wir vielleicht nicht vergessen, gerade weil wir das Publikum Nachwuchswissenschaftler vielleicht hier auch im Visier haben, dass es da noch ein ganz schönes Programm gibt, Marie Curie Förderung, Marie Curie Actions. Gibt es schon seit längerer Zeit und diese Förderung richtet sich vor allen Dingen an Nachwuchswissenschaftler, als individuelle Förderung. Ist eigentlich wie eine Postdoc-Stelle mit Untersetzung. Und die sind auch mehr oder weniger themenoffen. Und werden von der Kommission verwaltet. Also wir haben für Themen …
Also auch für Einzelwissenschaftler sozusagen relevant. Während die anderen Sachen in der Regel dann auch immer europäische Forschungszusammenschlüsse sind?
Verbünde. Ja das ist so das, was man klassischerweise als die europäische Verbundförderung bezeichnet.
Genau, können wir gleich nochmal drauf zu gehen. Welche Anforderungen man so erfüllen muss, um jetzt sozusagen überhaupt förderungswürdig zu sein. Ich versuche jetzt nur gerade mal, zusammenzufassen, ob wir das jetzt hier schon richtig aufgeschlüsselt haben. Also diese Rahmenprogramme definieren einfach generell die Wissenschaftsförderung in der EU, werden regelmäßig wieder neu aufgelegt. Jetzt sind wir bei dem 8. Durchlauf und jetzt hat das irgendwie auch einen hübschen Namen, weil macht man heutzutage halt so. Und man sieht irgendwie den Horizont und der ist dann 2020 erreicht. Und dann frage ich mich natürlich, was wohl hinter diesem Event Horizon tatsächlich zu finden ist. Und das ganze teilt sich in zwei Bereiche auf, nämlich irgendwie in die themendefinierten Sachen, das ist jetzt die Kommission und dann eben diesen themenoffenen Bereich, das macht dieser Forschungsrat, der als Agentur unabhängig arbeitet und das sind im Prinzip dann auch so die beiden Kontaktstellen, mit denen KOWI unter anderem kommuniziert?
Unter anderem ja.
Unter anderem. Also auf der Vergabeseite sozusagen.
Auf der Vergabeseite oder auf der Seite der Themengestalter oder der auch nachher, wir betreuen auch Wissenschaftler bei der Durchführung der Projekte, beim Management, die dann auch unsere Ansprechpartner oder die Vermittler sind, wenn es um die Abwicklung der Programme geht oder um Evaluierung, so all die Dinge, die wichtig nachher sind, um wirklich Erfolg zu haben.
Ja kommen wir doch dann mal auf die Seite der Wissenschaftler, die jetzt Interesse haben, an einem solchen EU-Programm teilzunehmen. Also mit der Ausnahme der eben erwähnten – wie hieß das Programm doch gleich, diese postdocartige Einzelförderung?
Marie Curie, Marie Sludoska Curie muss ich sagen.
Das ist so ein Sonderding. Also das ist jetzt anders als alles andere. Das ist jetzt sozusagen nur konkret für Einzelpersonen und alles andere ist Verbund?
Ja. Das Programm ist so komplex, dass wenn ich Sie jetzt korrigieren müsste, müsste man noch dazu sagen, dass auch in diesem Marie Sludoska Curie Programm auch noch so was wie graduierten Schulen, graduierten Kollegs drinstecken. Wo auch wieder Wissenschaftler mit mehreren Partnern zusammenarbeiten, aber den hat immer gemein die Nachwuchsförderung. Dort werden also Doktoranden gefördert. Wenn man aber jetzt wie hier auch ein Publikum an Nachwuchswissenschaftler anspricht, dann ist da ein großer Teil reserviert für die individuelle Förderung. Die heißen Stipendien, sind aber wirklich tolle, echte Stellen, die mit Geld untersetzt sind und ein echtes Projekt darstellen. Ja insofern hat das eine gewisse Sonderstellung.
Und wer ist jetzt so generell förderungsfähig? Also inwiefern was muss man überhaupt erfüllen, um auch nur in Frage zu kommen für eine EU-Förderung? Also muss man da fertig studiert haben? Ab wann kommt man überhaupt mit diesen Bereichen in Kontakt?
Ja also im weitesten Sinne ist eigentlich jeder angesprochen. Also wir haben schon gerade im Vorfeld drüber gesprochen. Sie wären auch sehr gut denkbar als Teil eines ...
Ich habe ja noch nicht mal studiert.
Ja das ist das schöne, das getragen vielleicht von einem topwissenschaftlichen Kern oder auch einem, der innovative Forschung macht, die Projekte, ich rede jetzt von den Verbundprojekten, also diesem Kern, oft so angelegt sind, dass man eben von der Grundlagenforschung bis hin zur Anwendung und auch der Kommunikation mit der Öffentlichkeit, dem Dialog Wissenschaft Gesellschaft vieles abdecken muss. Wenn wir jetzt aber nochmal zum Kern zurückkommen und nicht gleich das Vorurteil bestärken wollen, dass diese EU-Projekte wissenschaftlich nicht interessant oder konkurrenzfähig sind, dann ist normalerweise was wir sehen ist so ab Postdoclevel jemand in der Lage, in so einem Projekt aktiv mitzumachen. Ich rede jetzt nicht von den vielen hundert Stellen, die aus den Projekten finanziert werden und denen dann natürlich auch Doktoranden und vielleicht auch studentische Hilfskräfte finanziert werden. Aber diejenigen, die Projekte initiieren, sei es als Partner oder als Hauptherdenführer, als Project oder Principal Investigator, das heißt ja im EU-Jargon der Koordinator, die sind angefangen von Postdocs, Nachwuchsgruppenleiter bis hin dann natürlich zu Topwissenschaftlern, Professoren.
Aber die Projekte sind so divers angelegt, so breit, eben von der Anwendung bis hin zur jetzt sehr nahen angewandten Forschung, dass man für viele Akteure Platz hat. Je nachdem in welchem Programm man schaut. Der Forschungsrat, der nur Exzellenzforschung macht, da sind natürlich nur Wissenschaftler ab Postdoclevel gefragt, und die müssen durch ihre Publikationsleistung, ihre Vita überdurchschnittlich aktiv und erfolgreich sein. In den europäischen Verbundprojekten, wo es ja darum geht, gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen zu lösen, kann man das nicht nur auf exzellentem Grundlagenniveau tun, sondern da muss die Industrie dabei sein, da muss am besten Spinoffs kreiert werden und man muss sich eben auch um die Kommunikation der Ergebnisse kümmern.
Das sind sozusagen die Anforderungen, die man als Gruppe erfüllen muss.
Ja genau. Und das ist eigentlich das spannende. Natürlich eine Herausforderung für die Wissenschaftler, die erst mal sagen, ich habe eine tolle wissenschaftliche Idee, das sind unsere Hauptklienten als KOWI, weil wir primär den Hochschulen dienen. Das ist also unsere Hauptzielgruppe sind die Wissenschaftler an Hochschulen oder deren Unterstützer. Da ist ja der Normalfall, dass man eine tolle Idee hat und will die umsetzen. Kennt wahrscheinlich das nationale Forschungsfördersystem am besten, ist von der DFG verwöhnt, sagt, ich habe eine Idee, hier ich schlage die vor und gebt mir Geld. Hier muss man sehr gut schauen, wie die Idee eingebettet ist in ein Thema, was vorgegeben ist und wie man das kreativ mit den besten geeignetesten Gruppen umsetzt oder geeignetesten Partnern. Und das sind klassischerweise nicht meine liebsten Forscherfreunde überall in der Welt, die eigentlich das gleiche tun wie ich, sondern man muss da sehr breit schauen, wie man das ganze auch in die Anwendung führen kann.
Dadurch ergeben sich dann auch so interdisziplinäre Gruppen?
In jedem Fall interdisziplinär.
Nochmal wegen des Schwerpunkts, Hochschule heißt, dass jetzt Wissenschaftler an anderen Forschugnsgesellschaften davon ausgeschlossen sind? Nein, das heißt es nicht?
Nein.
Also grundsätzlich steht das Programm allen offen, die so die Qualifikationen und die richtigen Themen haben. Konkret KOWI kümmert sich vor allem um die Wissenschaftler an Hochschulen?
Wir kümmern uns auch um alle. Wir sind aber, und das zeigt auch die Entwicklung oder die Bedeutungszunahme dieser Forschungsrahmenprogramme, wenn ich mich in Brüssel umschaue, wir sitzen in einem Gebäude in der Nähe des Parlamentes und auch der Europäischen Kommission, also unsere Hauptministerium, also der Generaldirektion Forschung und Innovation, da haben in dem Gebäude schon die großen Wissenschaftsorganisationen, viele von denen, eigene Büros über die Jahre entwickelt. Und auch wir als KOWI, das ist vielleicht wissenschaftspolitisch interessant für uns, besonders bedeutsam, wir sind mal gestartet als einziges Haus am Platz in Brüssel für die deutschen Wissenschaftsorganisationen, weit vor meiner Zeit. Und es hieß noch damals Koordinationsstelle. Das heißt also, eine Einrichtung konnte sich anmaßen, die deutsche Wissenschaft dort koordiniert zu repräsentieren. Inzwischen hat jede der großen Wissenschaftsorganisationen, Max-Planck, Leibniz, Helmholtz, Fraunhofer, haben ihre eigenen Büros und bieten auch eigene Services an.
Und wir sind sozusagen dort aktiv, wo noch Beratungsbedarfe existieren für die Wissenschaftler aus den anderen Einrichtungen. Hochschulen haben dieses Büro über uns und forschungspolitisch sind die über das Büro der HRK in Brüssel vertreten. Insofern hat sich das so über die Jahre entwickelt, dass wir uns so an die Hochschulen richten als Hauptzielgruppe, die betreuungsbedürftig ist.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt eine Konkurrenzsituation, sondern das ist einfach nur, dass sich noch mehr Gruppen kümmern und dass man da auch zusammenarbeitet an solchen Sachen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wenn man jetzt sagen wir mal diese erforderlichen Ausbildungsgrade an Vine und Paperansammlungen zusammengetragen hat und auch ordentlich Ideen hat und der Meinung ist, dass man jetzt entweder für eine dieser strukturell vorgegebenen Forschungsplätze von Forschungsrat oder eben eines der Metathemen der kommissionsgestützten Förderung in Frage kommt, wie sollte man denn vorgehen? Also vielleicht oder erst mal, womit kann man einfach rechnen? Also was sind jetzt überhaupt so, also mit welcher Erwartungshaltung kann man da ran gehen? Also was ist realistisch, dass man das vor allem auch im ersten Schritt überhaupt öffnen kann? Also welche Gelder, welche Laufzeiten sind überhaupt denkbar?
Und damit verbunden, wie sollte man sich eigentlich als Wissenschaftler dann jetzt aufstellen? Weil ich denke, da kommen ja eine ganze Menge Fragen mit rein. So erst mal, wie finde ich da meine Kooperationspartner oder was brauche ich überhaupt für Kooperationspartner? Mit wie vielen anderen Ländern muss ich denn jetzt irgendwie mich zusammentun, um überhaupt da den Anforderungen zu genügen? Ja und wie geht man dann vor?
Ja das ist eine gute Frage oder ist schön, mal die Gelegenheit zu haben, da nochmal drauf hinzuweisen, dass es vermutlich der beste Rat wäre, sich im Vorfeld so ausführlich beraten zu lassen bei diesem riesigen Programm, mit so vielen Unterfördermöglichkeiten, mit auch dann immer wieder anderen Rahmenbedingungen, dass es ganz schlau wäre, sich meist an den Hochschulen oder fast alle Hochschulen haben Profis, die wir wiederum schlau machen oder das ist unser Auftrag, mit Informationen füttern, die dann aber erst mal Generalisten sind und einen guten Überblick haben über, was alles möglich ist.
Das heißt, es gibt in der Regel in jeder Universität auch schon mal eine Kontaktperson, die mehr oder weniger mit Ihnen oder mit einem der beiden Büros in Bonn und Brüssel oder im Idealfall vielleicht mit beiden kommuniziert?
Auf jeden Fall. Wo wir speziell für die, die heißen Multiplikatoren oder sind EU-Referenden oder Forschungsreferenden an den Hochschulen, an allen Forschungseinrichtungen, die wir speziell auch weiterbilden und die, die sollten unbedingt bekannt sein an den Einrichtungen, weil die sind die Erstanlaufstelle, sonst könnten wir mit unserem relativ kleinen Team von 13 Beratern oder 20 Personen, die wir überhaupt sind, gar nicht diesen Bedarf erfüllen. Und das ist also wie so ein Schneeballsystem in Deutschland aufgebaut. Und dann gibt es noch Kollegen von den nationalen Beratungseinrichtungen, Kontaktstellen. Aber vor allen Dingen sollte jemand, der Wissenschaftler ist, sich erst mal vor Ort beraten lassen. Denn meistens beginnt es so, sage ich aus eigener Erfahrung …
Also ist das in der Regel nur eine Person?
In der Regel, je nach Größe der Einrichtung. Also große, gerade exzellenzgeförderte Unis, die haben inzwischen also ein ganzes Team aufgebaut.
Dann vielleicht auch so themenspezifisch oder ist das in der Regel nur für die Uni an sich?
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wie die Hochschule auch diesen Servicebereich ausgebaut hat. Oft sind die schon so spezialisiert, dass es auch Themen sind oder die Kombination Thema und dann guckt man nicht nur Richtung EU, sondern auch was ist national möglich? Das ist so aus meiner Erfahrung eigentlich auch ein Idealzustand, weil man erst mal, wenn ich mir jetzt nochmal Sie vorstelle, Sie wären Wissenschaftler, haben eine tolle Idee, das ist ja meistens nicht so der Motivator in den meisten Fällen, dass man sagt, ich möchte das maximal komplizierteste, aufwendigste und mit den geringsten Förderwahrscheinlichkeiten versehene Programmelement finden, sondern man würde Sie fragen, was ist denn Ihre Idee? Und in welchem Setting wollen Sie die Idee umsetzen?
Genau, ich möchte den Berliner Hundekot in reine Energie übersetzen.
Dann werden wir mal schauen.
Müsste ich ja eigentlich mein Geld aus Berlin bekommen. Gibt es bloß keins.
Genau, denn oft stellt sich raus, das klingt vielleicht europäisch, aber es lässt sich vielleicht sogar ein nationales Programm dazu finden. Und manchmal ist das, was abschreckend klingt, europäisch bei näherer Beratung dann doch das Mittel der Wahl. Also im Idealfall würde man sagen, mein Thema, klassisch ist das so was wie Umweltforschung, globale Erderwärmung. Das sind so die Glücksfälle auch für uns als Berater, dass jemand sagt, das ist wirklich das, was ich nur europäisch im Verbund mit internationalen Partnern machen kann, denn das bietet das Rahmenprogramm. Und ich will auch dazu beitragen, dass daraus irgendwas gesellschaftlich relevantes herauskommt. Und diese Beratung, die würde aber vor allen Dingen erst mal an der Einrichtung laufen. Natürlich auch durch uns, aber wir sind dann schon sehr viel spezieller auf das Rahmenprogramm eingestellt.
Das heißt, mein erster Schritt wäre jetzt zu dem an meiner Hochschule platzierten Menschen, wo ich sagen kann, hier höre mal, ich brauche Geld für ein tolles Projekt. Gehe ich das national an, arbeite ich oder vielleicht ja auch spreche ich mit einer anderen Forschungsgesellschaft, das ist ja sicherlich auch noch eine Option?
Ja, wen bringt man sowieso schon mit? Haben Sie Ihre Lieblingsfirma im Gepäck.
Oder bin ich so größenwahnsinnig, dass ich irgendwie hier sowieso nur auf EU-Ebene andocken kann. Das wäre sozusagen jetzt der erste Schritt?
Ja, das wäre ja nicht größenwahnsinnig, aber ambitioniert.
Also das ist es bei mir auf jeden Fall.
Aber auch da würde ich dann schon mal einhaken, weil das ist ja größenwahnsinnig, aber wir würden vielleicht im gleich ersten Schritt in diesem netten Nachwuchsprogramm landen und dann ist es gar nicht mehr so groß, sondern auch ganz nett und machbar.
Okay.
Was auf jeden Fall – Sie fragten ja auch nach dem, was sollte man auf jeden Fall beachten, diese Programme sind sehr kompetitiv. Das heißt die Hürden sind hoch und man muss auf jeden Fall handwerklich gute Anträge einreichen. Und das führt uns immer wieder nicht zu dem eigennützigen Rat, zu sagen, ein Antrag ohne Beratung hat vermutlich wenig Chancen. Wenn man nicht das Glück hat, in einer EU-aktiven Gruppe zu sein oder in einem Umfeld, wo man von Kollegen oder im besten Falle vom Betreuer sieht, wie sehen Projekte aus, wie muss man die schreiben. Dass die Konkurrenz so hoch ist, dass man einfach mit einem DFG-sozialisierten Umfeld an dem auch an dem handwerklich vorbeischreibt vielleicht, an dem was in dem Rahmenprogramm gemacht werden müsste. Das ist ein einfaches Training. Also ich vergleiche das immer auch mit BMWF-Anträgen, die sind auch nicht so einfach zu schreiben. Man muss wissen, wie man es tut oder DFG-Anträgen. Die haben aber eine größere Tradition.
Oder es gibt auch national eben eine Menge Geld. Dass man also einen Antrag ohne Beratung wirklich nicht auf den Weg bringen sollte oder sich mal erkundigt, wie sehen handwerklich gute Anträge aus? Da kommt dann ein Teil auch der Beratung von uns.
Die nationalen Anträge darf man ja wahrscheinlich auch in deutsch schreiben und die europäischen sicher nur in englisch oder? Oder welche Sprachen sind erlaubt?
Ja, es gibt Juristen, die ... also theoretisch ist ja deutsch auch Amtssprache. Ich habe auch schon Juristen erlebt, die das durchfechten wollten, und sagten, ich schreibe hier meinen ERC-Antrag also für den Forschungsrat auf deutsch. Also rechtlich kann man das, es riskiert aber, dass man in Übersetzungsprogramme reingerät, die mit der Fachsprache im besten Falle überhaupt nichts anfangen können und ein Kauderwelsch bei Gutachtern landet, das dann vielleicht schon das KO in der ersten Runde heißt.
Aber es gibt ja auch Deutsche, die bei den nationalen Förderern, jetzt bei der DFG, englisch schreiben, auch mit dem Ziel, eine andere Gutachtergruppe anzusprechen.
Okay alles klar.
Verstehe.
Also ja das muss nicht unbedingt so schwierig sein.
Jaa. Nochmal zu diesem ,was kann ich überhaupt erwarten? Also sagen wir mal, wir wollen ja jetzt hier auch explizit über EU-Anträge reden. Also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass wir jetzt auch ein passendes Thema gefunden haben, was eben jetzt zu irgendeinem dieser gesetzten Themen passt oder eben in die Struktur reinpasst. Und was sind denn überhaupt die Mindestvoraussetzungen für das Team. Weil als Einzelperson, wenn man jetzt mal diese Nachwuchsförderung rauslässt, also man muss ja als Team antreten?
Ja. In diesen Verbundsettings, die einen Großteil des Rahmenprogramms ausmachen, ja. Und da muss man also mindestens drei Partner mitbringen, die auch in einem europäischen Vermischtheitsgrad auftreten müssen. Können also nicht im Normalfall nicht nur Deutsche sein, sondern es muss dann schon europäisch aufgestellt sein. In den geringsten Fällen sind die Projekte aber so klein, dass es drei Partner sind. Das leitet sich schon ab aus diesen vorgegebenen Themen, dass man also eine Breite abdecken muss, von der Entwicklung bis hin zur Umsetzung, dass man im Durchschnitt so bei 5/6/7/8 Partnern landet. Manche Projekte sind auch viel größer, haben eine größere Dimension. Aber man landet in den geringsten Fällen bei ganz schmalen Projekten. Was natürlich toll ist, wenn man international forschen möchte, weil was man auch erwähnen sollte, das ist eigentlich das größte weltweit offene Forschungsprogramm überhaupt.
Dieses Rahmenprogramm klingt ja erst mal europäisch. Es sind aber schon sehr viele Staaten assoziiert, die man gar nicht vermuten würde. Wie zum Beispiel Israel wird voll finanziert. Israelische Partner, isländische Partner, bei der Schweiz gibt es gerade Probleme, weil die ja diese Personenfreizügigkeit aufgekündigt haben und jetzt bestraft werden, dadurch dass sie nicht mehr direkt in dieses Rahmenprogramm...
An den Forschungsprogrammen teilnehmen...
Ja, haben Sie vielleicht auch schon aus den Augenwinkeln verfolgt. Und dann werden international Partner mit gefördert. Das sind also sogenannte Drittstaaten und die Industrienationen die können mitmachen. USA, Australien, bringen das eigene Geld mit, wenn in dem Antrag gezeigt werden kann, dass die essenzielle, wichtige Komponenten zu dem Projekt beitragen. Also man kann wirklich weltweit sein Team zusammenstellen.
Verstehe. Das heißt, selbst wenn man jetzt sozusagen mit nicht EU-assoziierten Forschergruppen arbeiten will, solange die ihren Teil finanziell beitragen, können sie trotzdem Teil dieses Forschungsprogramms sein?
Ja genau. Oder Sie haben …
Ist das häufig so? Also sind da häufig US-amerikanische Forschergruppen Teil solcher EU-Projekte?
Ja. Also ich nehme mal speziell den Fall der Gesundheitsforschung. Da ist es sogar so, dass das National Institute of Health, also der amerikanische Förderer öffnet seine Programme für die Europäer und im Gegenzug ist dieser ganze Gesundheitsbereich geöffnet auch für amerikanische, US-amerikanische Wissenschaftler, die können mitmachen und werden direkt finanziert.
Das heißt man kann auch an einem von den USA ausgelobten Forschungsprogramm und wo da quasi die Primärförderung kommt, sagen, ich will aber Teil des Forschergruppenverbandes sein und möchte gerne anteilig dann aus dem EU-Topf gefördert werden?
Ja.
Das ist aber dann nochmal ein anderer Modus oder?
Das wäre jetzt vielleicht so ein Fall, wo Sie sagen, Sie sind an der Hochschule gut beraten und da würde man schauen, wollen Sie eigentlich mit US-Amerikanern arbeiten oder mit Europäern und dann gibt es eben noch eine ganze Welt von Programmen außerhalb Europas. Man muss auch sagen, wenn wir jetzt über das europäische Forschungsprogramm sprechen oder das EU-Programm, es gibt eben, wenn man genauer hinschaut auch noch für den Umweltbereich oder auch für den medizinischen Bereich noch andere europäische Programme, die nicht so wissenschaftsorientiert sind oder forschungsorientiert, die aber ab und zu auch mal in Frage kommen, wenn man eine bestimmte auch anwendungsorientiertere Idee umsetzen möchte. Das gehört dann auch nochmal zu unserem Beratungsportfolio dazu, diese Programme, die außerhalb des Horizon2020 stehen, im Blick zu behalten.
Ja, also andere europäische oder jetzt international andere Programme?
Ich rede jetzt von den europäischen, die wir als KOWI, weil wir eben die europäischen Programme oder Förderungen im Blick haben. Aber wenn man international schaut, gibt es nochmal deutlich mehr Programme. Also ich will nicht sagen, das Geld liegt auf der Straße, aber es gibt für die, die Profiberater sind wie uns, eben viele Möglichkeiten für Sie als Wissenschaftler oder auch als junger Wissenschaftler, der noch nicht vermutlich den Überblick haben kann, was es so alles gibt oder Programme verändern sich, sie mit zu unterstützen. Und das sollte man auf jeden Fall nutzen.
Und gibt es noch andere Länder wie die USA, die so einen ähnlichen Deal haben mit Europa?
Ja immer wieder gibt es solche Kooperationsabkommen. Die gibt es natürlich, wir sind ja deutsche Wissenschaftler, dann die vielleicht nur mit Deutschland geschlossen sind. Gibt es ein ganzes internationales Büro, die diese Programme oder wissenschafts- WTZ-Abkommen, Wissenschaftlich-technologisches-Zusammenarbeits-Abkommen, betreuen. Und da gibt es immer mal so Unterprogramme oder auch Zeiten, wo Abkommen geschlossen werden, wo diese Öffnung von Programmen möglich ist. Ja das macht …
Aber das ist dann meistens von so bestimmten Subsystemen. Also Beispiel war ja eben national health, es geht jetzt nicht generell für die Forschung in den USA, sondern eben konkret eben in diesem Bereich ist es so, in anderen ist es vielleicht nicht so.
Ja.
Okay. Also da kann man sich ganz gut verlieren in den Details und man ist gut beraten, wenn man beraten ist sozusagen?
Es könnte helfen ja, um möglichst zum Ziel zu kommen. Das betrifft jetzt auch dieses Rahmenprogramm, das ist auch ein häufiges Thema dann bei dieser vielleicht Analyse, wo ist der beste Platz für meine Idee, und wie kann ich den angehen, da spielt einmal das Timing eine Rolle. Ich sagte ja schon, dass manche Programme oder die meisten einmal im Jahr so eine Öffnung haben mit einer Deadline. Das ist dann immer Punkt 5 Uhr in Brüssel einzureichen elektronisch. Und dann ist es eben auch eine Frage des Timings. Wenn Sie Nachwuchswissenschaftler sind, Ihre Stelle läuft aus, Sie brauchen eine Finanzierung in absehbarer Zeit, dann muss man halt gucken, wann beginnt man rechtzeitig damit, sich auch um die Nachfinanzierung zu kümmern. Und da muss man eben auch schauen, wann ist welches Programm geöffnet, wie lange ist die Evaluierungszeit, wann kann ich mich auch orientieren? Wann habe ich Bescheid, ob ich gefördert werde oder nicht? Und wann fließt das Geld vielleicht im existenziellsten Fall?
Wo ich selber jetzt ein bisschen wenig Einblick habe, wie selbstverständlich ist es denn eigentlich, dass diese Gruppen sich so ohne weiteres finden? Also ich meine, ich vermute mal, wenn ich jetzt in irgendeinem Bereich forsche, dann verfolgt man natürlich ohnehin die Arbeit anderer Forschergruppen zwangsläufig durch deren Papersveröffentlichungen. Und wahrscheinlich trifft man sich regelmäßig zu Schnittchen auf der nächsten Konferenz. Das heißt, man hat da wahrscheinlich schon so ein bisschen sein Umfeld, aber vielleicht sucht man ja auch manchmal noch potenzielle Partner. Ist das irgendwie auch Teil Ihrer Arbeit, wirklich diese Forschergruppen sich auch finden zu lassen? Also gibt es da auch so ein bisschen so eine Börse? Nach dem Motto, wir haben da so ein Projekt, aber uns fehlt da noch eine Komponente oder ist das nicht so Ihr Ding?
Das betrifft auch einen Teil unserer Beratungsarbeit. Das ist auch ein ganzes Feld, wo man aus der Kommission sogar heraus, diesen Wunsch nach Verpartnerung gerecht zu werden, Datenbanken. Also eigentlich so was wie Ehefindungsinstitute installiert hat, die mal mit mehr oder weniger Erfolg funktionieren. Also auf dieser ganz abstrakten und offenen Ebene tummeln sich oft leider eben nur die hoffnungslosen Fälle. Und eigentlich sucht man ja ... also vielleicht etwas provokant formuliert, da mag schon mal der eine oder andere auch glücklich geworden sein, aber meist kennt man sich nicht. Und wenn man in so einem Projekt 3-5 Jahre, so sind die Laufzeiten. Sie fragten ja auch gerade danach. Zusammengeht, auch mit einer gewissen Verantwortung für das Budget, ist es oft geraten, dass man zumindest ein Qualitätsscreening hat in den Partnerschaften. Wir arbeiten als Brüsseler Büro der KOWI zusammen mit den europäischen Büros anderer Mitgliedsstaaten.
Wir sind da informell organisiert in einer Gruppe die heißt IGLU, informal group of liason offices. Und über diesen sehr intensiven kollegialen Austausch, wir haben also verschiedene Arbeitsgruppen, treffen uns einmal im Monat, läuft auch so was wie Partnervermittlung. Wenn man also sagt, wir suchen noch einen Partner. Es geht ja auch in gewisser Weise darum, natürlich immer auf exzellentem und passendem Niveau, aber das auch europäisch balanciert aufzustellen so eine Projektpartnerschaft. Vermitteln wir schon mal Partner oder fragen an, kennt ihr vielleicht den oder den Spezialisten? Und vermitteln die. Oft ist es aber auch nochmal eine Frage der Beratung, bei den Wissenschaftlern nachzufragen, überlegt mal, wenn ihr nochmal euer ganzes Netzwerk beleuchtet, auch nochmal spezieller hinterfragt, da kommt auch oft heraus, dass sie vielleicht doch über Partner oder Industriepartnerschaften besser vernetzt sind, als es auf den ersten Blick scheint. Dass man eher über bekannte Netzwerke geht und die entsprechenden fehlenden Kompetenzen noch in das Projekt rein nimmt.
Wie muss denn die Themenstruktur genau sein? Also wenn man jetzt sagt, was war das, drei Länder müssen beteiligt sein mindestens?
Drei Partner, drei Länder.
Ja, genau, wenn man erst mal dieses Kernkonsortium hat, dann ist man theoretisch frei, zu sagen, wie man das gerne weiter ergänzt.
Egal wie viele es insgesamt sind oder steigt dann diese Zahl auch?
Wenn ich irgendwie drei und zwei aus einem anderen Land habe, dann kann ich irgendwie nochmal 20 aus dem eigenen Land dazu packen, dann wäre das sozusagen, also das ist nicht wahrscheinlich, aber es ist möglich technisch?
Ja.
Nur um das zu verstehen. Hätte ja auch sein können, dass man, keine Ahnung, wenn man irgendwie 10 ist, dass man dann vier Länder abdecken muss oder so. Aber das ergibt sich dann wahrscheinlich auch von alleine.
Ja. Die kommen auch …
Also was genau definiert denn jetzt, kommt aus einem Land? Also muss das sozusagen ein Institut sein, eine Forschergruppe mit einer Mindestzahl, reicht da ein einzelner Wissenschaftler, der irgendwie in so einem Land ist? Also was ist da sozusagen die Korngröße?
Die Korngröße ist dann die juristische Einheit. Also wenn der Wissenschaftler an einer Hochschule ist, dann ist der Vertragspartner die Hochschule, aber der Projektträger, also der echte Kopf und der Macher ist dann der Wissenschaftler. Das kann der Leiter einer Arbeitsgruppe sein, aber es kann auch ein Postdoc sein, wenn er die Verantwortung bekommt und eingeladen wir, mitzumachen, dann kann das auch ein Postdoc sein oder ein Nachwuchsgruppenwissenschaftler.
Und wenn jetzt so eine Teamgruppe gebildet ist und jemand wechselt die Hochschule? Dann geht das aber mit der Person  mit und verbleibt nicht bei der Hochschule? Sondern es ist sozusagen an den Forscher gebunden, auch wenn der Vertrag mit der Uni gemacht wird. Wechselt der dann sozusagen seine Hochschule, dann muss dieser Vertrag entsprechend angepasst werden?
Genau, dann wird der Vertrag übernommen.
Okay, das heißt er darf dann auch nirgendwohin wechseln, wo dann auf einmal die Parität, die Länderparität in Gefahr ist?
Nein, dann ist es zu spät, es wird dann nicht evaluiert. Also es gibt schon noch Gutachter auch, die drauf schauen können auf so ein Projekt und das begleiten, wie so externe Experten und da spielt dann aber kein Länderproports mehr die Rolle.
Aber vielleicht mal jenseits so einer technischen Betrachtung, was ist denn eine gute Teamzusammenstellung? Also was ist denn so Ihre Erfahrung, welche Projektgruppen da auch mit der notwendigen Beständigkeit und internen Kommunikation, die ja nicht ganz unwichtig ist, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es da auch Konstellationen gibt, die etwas unglücklicher verlaufen, können Sie da irgendwelche Lehren teilen oder Tipps geben, was man da falsch machen kann? Oder was da so aufgefallen ist, was vielleicht nicht so gut gelaufen ist?
Also am Ende sind es ja Menschen, die kooperieren, da ist dann eigentlich jetzt jenseits von so kann es nicht laufen, ist eigentlich immer der human factor das entscheidende. Wenn Dinge schief laufen, dann ist es nie so, dass ich erlebt habe, dass man sagt, ein Nachwuchsgruppenleiter, nur weil der nicht gut schon etabliert ist, ist das perse ein schlechtes Konstrukt. Es gibt Verwerfungen, die eigentlich eher so auf der zwischenmenschlichen Ebene laufen. Also wie gesagt, wenn Partner sich nicht bekannt sind und erst mal zusammengehen sollen im Beutereflex hier irgendwie Geld abzuholen noch in letzter Minute an Bord genommen werden, die dann gerade, manchmal bei kleinen Firmen, kleine mittlere Unternehmen sind auch ein Schwergewicht im Rahmenprogramm, die sollen also speziell Budget abgreifen in den Projekten. Wenn die dann insolvent werden über den Programmverlauf oder eine Verwaltung in einer Einrichtung nicht trainiert ist, mit solchen Programmen umzugehen, mit den Regularien.
Wenn einmal alle zehn Jahre so ein EU-Projekt da aufschlägt, und die Verwaltung überfordert ist, dass es Schwierigkeiten gibt, aber es gibt eigentlich keine Grundkonstellation, wo man sagt, die verhindert jetzt eine erfolgreiche Durchführung.
Okay. Also im Prinzip kann man, wenn man meint, die technisch inhaltlich richtigen Partner gefunden zu haben, mit denen man so halbwegs ganze Sätze sprechen kann, dann hat man eigentlich schon die Anforderungen, die ersten Anforderungen erfüllt?
Die ersten Anforderungen erfüllt. Man muss auch im Antrag einen ganz großen Teil beschreiben, das ist auch anders als in den nationalen Programmen oft, wie das Management des Projektes durchgeführt wird. Und das ist auch Teil der Begutachtung. Dafür gibt es Geld. Und auf jeden Fall sollte man jemandem raten, der nicht selber der Hauptherdenführer sein will, der Koordinator, dass man sich überlegt, mit wem man sich da in ein Projekt rein begibt, weil die größte Macht liegt natürlich in den Händen des Koordinators, der Geld vergibt, der entscheidet, wie das Projekt gemanagt wird. Und wenn man da …
Also so was gibt es überhaupt erst mal. Also es gibt zwar eine Projektgruppe mit ihren Teilnehmern, aber einer hat quasi..
... den Hut auf. Okay.
Einer hat den Hut auf.
Und ist auch der Hauptansprechpartner gegenüber der Kommission. Es ist nicht so, dass alle gleichberechtigt mit dem einen Betreuer, der in der Kommission sitzt und dieses Projekt begleitet oder zwei, einer für die Finanzen, einer für die Inhalte, dass da jeder kommuniziert, sondern es geht immer über diesen Koordinator. Und der verteilt das Geld, der managt das ganze. Wenn man da nicht glücklich ist und auch jemanden erwischt hat, der nicht geeignet ist, so eine komplexere Sache zu leiten, dann kann man schon Pech haben. Also das ist vielleicht der eine wichtige Punkt. Ich habe mal erlebt einen Bürgermeister einer kleinen südfranzösischen Stadt, der auch ein Topwissenschaftler war, aber das so im Nebenamt machte, das war also ein wunderbar vorbereitetes begleitetes Projekt, weil der nicht nur diese wissenschaftlichen Kompetenzen hatte, sondern auch, wie sich zeigte, also Bürgermeister.
Politische Skills hatte.
Die Chance hatte, komplizierte Settings zu leiten.
Wenn man jetzt sein Thema hat und man hat sein Team, was ist denn das jetzt so für ein Trip, den man da machen muss, um auch wirklich ans Ziel zu geraten? Also man muss halt jetzt einen Antrag schreiben. Was bringt das so mit sich und wie arbeiten die Wissenschaftler dann auch mit KOWI zusammen? Ist das so Ihr Kern? Also ist das die Phase, wo Sie am meisten beraten oder ist das eher im Vorfeld? Wo sind denn so die Schwerpunkte?
Wir haben eigentlich drei große Arbeitsfelder. Das eine ist die Information, wir geben einen Newsletter raus tagesaktuell und decken damit das gesamte Rahmenprogramm ab. Und auch etwas den forschungsförderpolitischen Überbau. Also was sind gerade für politische Papiere wichtig für die einzelnen Themenbereiche? Gibt es gerade im Bereich Umwelt neue Greenpaper, die auch wichtig sind für die Antragstellung oder für die Positionierung von Themen? Dass also die Informationen die Weiterbildung, ich sagte schon, dass wir mit diesen EU-Referenden, den Multiplikatoren eng zusammenarbeiten, da Schulungsseminare anbieten. Die können auch von Wissenschaftlern besucht werden, aber klassischerweise ist das schon so ein Expertentum, dass wir uns da eher an die Servicestellen richten. Und dann kommt der Bereich der tatsächlichen Beratung. Wir sind also viel zu Informationsveranstaltungen unterwegs. Das ist alles so Vorfeldinformation. Um so Dinge zu tun, die wir hier gerade mal im Podcastformat versuchen, anzureißen.
Die wir so über Halbtagesseminare, Tagesseminare zu verschiedenen Unterprogrammen abdecken. Und dann kommt der Fall, wo wir eben auch, wenn Sie anrufen und haben Ihre Idee oder schreiben den Antrag, Sie konkret beraten oder lesen Anträge gegen, wenn die dann schon weiter ausgereift sind oder überlegen auch mit den Ansprechpartnern vor Ort, die das meist ja vor Ort auch unterstützen so mehr als Generalisten, wie kann der Antrag noch besser werden? Dann gibt es eben die nationalen Beratungsstellen noch, nationale Kontaktstellen, die das ganze noch fachspezifisch begleiten. Sodass im besten Fall so ein ganzes Team für Sie als Wissenschaftler auch auf der Beraterebene existiert, dass Sie sich an Bord nehmen können, um diesen Antrag optimal auf den Weg zu bringen. Und da muss ich eben nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass das wirklich so eine hohe Konkurrenz ist, dass man da an jeder Stelle des Antrags, der durchaus so 100 Seiten haben kann, das Gold glänzend machen muss, um die Gutachter zu überzeugen, dass das wirklich die Topidee ist, die gefördert wird.
Zu dem zweiten Teil, den Sie sagten, diese Seminare, die Sie machen, wer kann daran teilnehmen? Und unter welchen Bedingungen?
Jeder der Interesse hat. Also wir können mit unserem Mandat keine Consultens schlauer machen, die das ja oft schon selber sind. Aber alle Teilnehmer aus dem öffentlichen Bereich, aus unserem Trägerverein im weitesten Sinne können die  Seminare besuchen.
Also jeder der sozusagen auch in Frage käme, einen Antrag zu stellen, könnte auch einfach sagen, hier da findet super Seminar ... also die Seminare finden einfach statt und man bewirbt sich dann darauf und sagt, ich würde da gerne dran teilnehmen, ist noch ein Platz frei?
Genau. Ja, die organisieren wir oft vor Ort an den Hochschulen, dann werden die in der Region oder in der Hochschule publik gemacht und wir kommen dann dahin.
Ach so okay, das findet gar nicht jetzt in Brüssel statt, sondern in …
Beides. Wir machen Seminare in Brüssel, aber mit Blick auch auf die Reisebudgets unserer Klientel, der Wissenschaftler und auch der Zeit, machen wir eigentlich nur Seminare in Brüssel, wo wir tatsächlich Mehrwert bieten. Wir laden die Kommission ein auf kleinem Dienstwege, dass die dazu kommen. Auch bei Projektbesprechungen. Aber alles was vor Ort ist, so Informations- und Weiterbildungsdinge, die laufen vor allen Dingen in Deutschland. Da sind so 160 Veranstaltungen im Jahr stemmen wir. Und die sind dann in der Regel eigentlich deutschlandweit in Absprache mit den Unterstützern vor Ort.
Aber ist sicherlich auch mal interessant, das Geschehen so vor Ort mitzubekommen oder? Da weht dann auch nochmal ein ganz anderer Wind.
Ja, das ist eigentlich so das was wir versuchen zu vermitteln und was auch oft transportiert wird in den Feedbacks der Teilnehmer, dass man selbst wenn wir mit Spezialisten reden oder Wissenschaftlern, die es eigentlich besser wissen müssten, dann heißt es auch oft, gerade wenn wir noch an diese psychotherapeutische Begleitung auf den Weg bringen müssten bei abgelehnten Anträgen, dann heißt es oft, die in Brüssel, was die hier mit meinem Antrag gemacht haben und dann wird es auf einmal diese Blackbox Brüssel wird ein Bollwerk von Bürokraten und böswilligen Menschen und was wir vermitteln ist dann, da sitzen dann zum Teil super ausgebildete ganz engagierte Leute, die das beste wollen und versuchen, die Rahmenbedingungen vermittelbarer zu machen, damit man versteht, dass vieles Gründe hat, was so passiert wie es läuft. Und dann eben dieses „die in Brüssel“ aufzubrechen. Und das hilft glaube ich auch am Ende, um erfolgreich zu sein.
Wie viele Veranstaltungen sind es dann, die wirklich in Brüssel durchgeführt werden von diesen 160?
Also ich zähle jetzt nur die, die wir selber organisieren.
Ja genau, die meine ich auch.
Das sind etwa 30. Wir haben aber in meinem Büro, in unserem Büro in Brüssel haben wir eine Konferenzinfrastruktur, die wird eigentlich täglich genutzt für Konferenzen, Projektmeetings, das sind Projekte, die sich vorbereiten. Projekte die mal die Kommission treffen wollen. Projekte die müssen also zur Halbzeit ungefähr einen Bericht abliefern gegenüber internen Gutachtern, die das Projekt begleiten. Wo diese Projektmeetings stattfinden.
Ach so das heißt, auch wenn man schon selbst wenn man schon in einem Projekt steckt, kann man unter Umständen sogar in Form mindestens dieses Konferenzraums auch bei KOWI quasi eine Dienstleistung erhalten, indem man sagt, okay wir treffen uns jetzt einfach mal da. Da müssen wir nicht nochmal Hotel buchen und so weiter.
Ja genau. Sie werden da unterstützt und Tipps für, wo essen wir am Abend, versehen.
Bis ins letzte Detail.
Dieser Raum ist wunderschön und sehr bekannt auch bei der Kommission, weil wir eben 25 Jahre da vor Ort schon sind. Und das hat auch den Charakter eines neutralen Raumes, wo es auch oft bei so sensiblen Dingen, wie man ein Thema präsentiert darum geht, nicht sofort zu sagen, wir wollen hier massiv Druck ausüben aus Interesse eines Landes, Bayerns, Berlins oder wie auch immer oder einer einzelnen Forschungseinrichtung. Das ist bekannt dafür, dass wir so ein relativ neutrales Setting liefern und deshalb läuft das eigentlich ganz gut. Und wir sind unter anderem auch in Brüssel, um informelle Kontakte in die Kommission zu pflegen und die dann auch mal für Sie, wenn Sie Wissenschaftler sind, anzuwenden. So dass man mal einen Kollegen anrufen kann und sagt, was haltet ihr davon, außerhalb des ganz formalen Prozederes? Das ist in Brüssel nicht ganz unwichtig. Glaube ich, das macht auch Spaß.
Mediatorische Tätigkeit.
Ja, intermediäre
Vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen zum Geld. Also haben wir gehört, 80 Milliarden stecken da in diesem Gesamtetat drin, das ist jetzt über die volle Laufzeit, klingt erst mal sehr viel. Aber es teilt sich schon mal durch sieben Jahre, also was ist das dann so, 11 Milliarden pro Jahr. Welcher Größenordnung beantragt man denn? Also wie hoch kann man denn da gehen? Inwiefern ist jetzt die konkrete finanzielle Forderung schon ein Problem? Welche Rolle spielt das Geld, wie groß oder klein sollte man denken?
Ja das ist auch eine wichtige Frage, die natürlich jeden beschäftigt, der sagt, was kriege ich denn eigentlich für den Aufwand? Das ist mit allem was wir hier gerade besprechen, vielleicht verständlich, dass das auch nicht so ganz platt zu beantworten ist, weil das Programm so viele verschiedene Förderlinien hat. Also so ein Stipendium oder diese Marie-Curie-Förderung für einen individuellen Wissenschaftler, die bewegt sich dann am unteren Ende. Ist natürlich auch wesentlich kleiner als ein riesiges Verbundprojekt. Wenn man ganz grob mal sprechen wollte, bei einem Verbundprojekt mit 5-6 Partnern redet man vielleicht von Budgets zwischen 3-6/7 Millionen Euro. Das ist jetzt aber wirklich sehr grob gesprochen und man müsste im Detail hinschauen, was da eigentlich gemacht wird. Denn auch die Größe dieser Projekte richtet sich immer bei den themengetriebenen Forschungsprojekten darum, was soll gemacht werden und was ist, da steht immer ein Preistag hinter.
Also wenn wir jetzt drüber reden würden, für Ihr Gebiet gibt es eine Ausschreibung, dann würde dahinter sofort stehen, das Projekt, für das Sie sich vielleicht interessieren, wo das und das gemacht werden soll, vielleicht ein neues Alzheimermedikament entwickelt wird, dann steht da ein Preis dahinter, den die Kommission geben möchte. Was dann noch wichtig ist, ist überhaupt zu verstehen, wie die Projekte finanziert werden. Und das ist jetzt mit diesem Horizon2020 deutlich vereinfacht worden. Das heißt ein Wissenschaftler sowohl aus der Industrie als auch aus der Hochschule der bekommt für sein Forschungs- und Entwicklungsprogrammprojekt 100% Förderung und dann nochmal 25% Overhead, auch so eine Gemeinkostenpauschale, die alles abdeckt was die Verwaltung angeht. Und oft, wenn man Glück hat, an einer Richtung ist, wo man auch einen Teil dieses Overheads zurück bekommt, bekommt man eben von den 25% auch nochmal freies Geld zurück.
Von der Universität dann?
Von der Universität. Das zahlt die Kommission dann an den juristischen Partner, das ist die Hochschule und die verteilt das intern.
Okay, aber sozusagen man kriegt erst mal da Geld was man braucht und die Uni kriegt sozusagen Geld dafür, um das zu managen und um dafür auch Support bereitzustellen und wenn die selber der Meinung sind, naja 25% so viel brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht, hier hast du nochmal ein bisschen was, dann ist das deren Sache?
Ja. Und dann gibt es Projekte, die in diesem ganz innovations- und anwendungsnahen Bereich sind, wo Prototypen entwickelt werden sollen, die gehen dann so richtig ins große Geld.
Wie groß ist da die Schwankung? Also was sind so übliche kleinste Projekte? Also was würde man jetzt als kleines EU-Projekt bezeichnen, was würde man als durchschnittliche Größe und was wäre fett? Nur mal so eine Hausnummer.
Fett, es gibt auch noch ein Programm FET, das ist auch nochmal Future Emerging Technologies. Das schreibt sich aber FET. Auch ein kleines schlankes. Da sind eigentlich vielleicht ja, das passt deshalb, weil es kleinere Projektpartnerschaften sind so 3-5/6 Partner. Und ich mag diese Verallgemeinerung nicht, aber ich verstehe, dass Sie mich da gerne hinführen wollen, damit man überhaupt so einen Grip bekommt?
Ja um einfach ein Gefühl zu kriegen.
Das sind dann so 3-5 Millionen Euro für 3 Jahre Laufzeit. Wenn wir auf der ganz extremen Seite schauen, dann sind das solche Projekte.
Mit wie vielen Partnern ist das?
Vielleicht 5 Partner.
5 Partner, 5 Millionen, 3 Jahre.
Also klein ist dann vielleicht, ich glaube was jeder rausbekommen möchte ist eine Postdocstelle, Doktorandenstelle und Verbrauchsmittel in so einem Projekt. Reisemittel sind sowieso größer anzusetzen als in einer Dimension, die man national kennt. Weil das natürlich auch klar ist, es geht um Vernetzung, es geht um Abstimmung, Treffen.
Da wird viel geflogen.
Da wird ein bisschen geflogen. Aber das liegt dann auch in der Hand der Antragsteller, zu sagen, was ist ökonomisch? Und das ist nicht so wissenschaftsfern, dass man sagt, da ist jetzt nur noch so ein Reiseclub unterwegs. Wenn ich mich gerade erinnere, wo ich Sie anschaue, auch wieder Sternstunde der Beratung, wenn man Partner hat oder auch erfahrene EU-Projektteilnehmer, die immer wieder, also als Wiederholungstäter antreten und sagen, ich bin immer mit den Rahmenprogrammen unterwegs und mache europäische Forschung, da kommt dann noch so eine Komponente dazu, dass die Leuchten in den Augen kriegen und sagen oft, mir ist ganz wichtig, Nachwuchswissenschaftler auszubilden in den besten Settings, in den besten Umfeldern. Und das ist eben auch ein Aspekt, den man nicht vernachlässigen sollte bei diesen Projekten, dass da immer Postdocs oder zumindest Doktoranden eingestellt werden, die in den Genuss kommen, in einem europäischen Team auch Geld zu haben, um andere Orte kennenzulernen, auch andere Themengebiete.
Weil wir reden ja über interdisziplinäre Projekte, die jetzt nicht so schmalspurorientiert sind, dass man da an seinem Lehrstuhl da mehr oder weniger vor sich hinforscht und überhaupt nicht weiß, was in der Welt passiert. Und das ist auch was tolles zu erleben, wenn Wissenschaftler sagen, neben dem tollen Forschen mit Toppartnern, ist mir wichtig, dass meine Nachwuchswissenschaftler optimal gefördert in die Welt starten. Und das hat natürlich auch mit den Reisegeldern zu tun. Wenn wir jetzt aber nochmal zu Ihrer Frage zurück zu diesen Vergleichsskala von Größenordnungen am anderen Ende der Skala schauen, dann sind das im Moment diese FET-Flagships zum Beispiel Future and Emergine Technology Flagships. Da hat fast jeder schon in der Tagespresse darüber gelesen, weil davon gibt es nur zwei. Die tauchen inzwischen lese ich schon Bücher, also populärwissenschaftliche Bücher, wo die so als Referenzprojekte erwähnt werden, wo also visionäre Forschung, zur Zeit in zwei Themengebieten umgesetzt werden soll.
Das ist einmal die Hirnforschung und einmal der Bereich Grafen, also Materialentwicklung.
Ich frage Sie gleich, ob Sie da Assoziationen haben zu Anwendungen. Und die sind also Netzwerke von über 100 Partnern, Knoten äußerst komplex, die bis zu 100 Millionen Euro Geld haben sollen. Die aber, das muss man auch sagen, nicht ausfinanziert sind aus dem Rahmenprogramm. Die bekommen so in etwa 25% dieser 100 Millionen Euro und müssen sehen, wo der Rest herkommt, um diese visionäre Forschung.
Das tolle Zeug.
Ach verstehe, die müssen sich dann zum Beispiel mit der Industrie dann noch unterhalten.
Ja die Industrie oder auch nationale Förderer.
Ja, die aber jetzt gerade an diesen Themen dann auch nochmal ein besonderes Interesse hat, weil das sind ja auch so Themen, die jetzt sagen wir mal sich ein bisschen durchgesetzt haben in der Wissenschaftsszene als, da müssen wir ran, das ist wichtig, das hat Zukunftspotenzial. Das Grafen gehört ja da sicherlich dazu.
Die sind, wenn Sie mir alle noch folgen, durch diesen kleinen Exkurs durch den Dschungel eines Rahmenprogrammes. Es gibt dann noch einen Körper, also eine Institution, die gegründet wurde außerhalb der Kommission. Das European Institute of Technology. Das sitzt in Budapest. Was auch große Verbünde fördert. Und diese FET-Flagships sind eigentlich eher wissenschaftsgetrieben und auch aus der Wissenschaftscommunity entstanden. Und dieses European Institute of Technology fördert Projekte, die heißen Kicks, Knowledge and Innovation Communitys. Die haben auch die Dimensionen mehrere zig Partnerknoten in den Mitgliedsstaaten zusammenzuführen und haben aber noch viel mehr als diese Großprojekte der FET-Flagships, die Industrie an Bord. Und dort sollen tatsächlich Spinoffs entstehen. Also noch wissenschafts... oder das Innovationsdreieck, dieses Triangle, abgebildet werden aus der Wirtschaft, der Wissenschaft und auch der Ausbildung diese Ebenen abdecken.
Und da ist die Idee, das wirklich ganz wirtschaftsnah auch nach Auslaufen der Förderung dann die Wirtschaft einsetzt und dann diese Projektideen trägt. Da ist zum Beispiel eins entstanden jetzt im Bereich Healthy Aging, auch so ein großes Thema, was weltweit den Umgang mit der alternden Gesellschaft, gesundes Altern.
Alt aber nicht gebrechlich sozusagen. Europäisches Institute für Innovation und Technologie. Das darf ja nicht fehlen Innovation.
Ja.
Sozusagen völlig, wir Computerleute sagen immer, fully buzzword compliant.
Ich verwende wahrscheinlich schon viel mehr Buzzwords als dem Durchschnittsbürger lieb ist, aber ich könnte Sie noch volltexten damit.
Ist nicht ganz einfach mit all diesen Räten und Instituten und Gremien usw. und Kommissionen, da kann man schnell ins Schleudern kommen. Aber naja, ich habe zumindest den Überblick noch so halbwegs. Also viele bemühen sich und um nochmal auf die Finanzierungsgeschichte zurückzukommen. Also 3-5 Millionen ist so ein Beispiel für ein eher kleines Projekt. Aber das ist sagen wir mal, wenn man das Gefühl hat, um seine Forschung zu machen, dass man so in diesem Rahmen eigentlich auch Geld bräuchte, das wäre schon mal ein Grund auch überhaupt erst über einen EU-Antrag nachzudenken, so dass jetzt nicht gerade zufällig in einem nationalen Programm absehbar ist, dass man das auch bekommen könnte. Wenn es darüber hinaus geht und jetzt weiß ich nicht, wo man jetzt so den Mittelbereich taxieren kann, ich meine 100 Millionen auf der anderen Seite und das ist ja dann auch nur noch eine Teilfinanzierung.
10-15.
Also so 10-15 und das ist dann auch immer noch mit dieser Vollfinanzierung verbunden?
Ja.
Also alles was jetzt nicht so ein Over the Top Thema ist und nochmal besondere Weihen erhält, kann auch immer mit einer Vollfinanzierung rechnen, man muss halt nur seinen beantragten Betrag, den man ja letztlich auch selber festlegt, einfach legitimieren können. Und man legitimiert ihn natürlich durch die Relevanz des Themas. Man legitimiert ihn durch das Profil der teilnehmenden Gruppen und konkreten Wissenschaftler. Ich schätze mal, das macht sicherlich was her, wenn man jetzt auch ein paar erfahrene alte Hasen an Bord hat, aber das eben dann auch genauso eben mit dem Argument, hier junge Wissenschaftler, Postdocs etc. Oder besonderes große europäische Spreizung, dass man das damit auch noch mit argumentieren kann.
Ja und man belegt es auch mit dem Arbeitsplan, der dann auch ausgereift in den Projektanträgen dargelegt wer welche Arbeiten macht und wer welches Budget dafür bekommen kann auch. Und ich würde auch gerade Nachwuchswissenschaftler oder noch nicht so etablierten Wissenschaftlern Mut machen, sich mal Gedanken zu machen, europäisch auch sich umzuschauen oder vielleicht zu beteiligen, weil gerade die Begutachtungsverfahren auch die Offenheit für neue Ideen, Plätze da lässt, wo man vielleicht in manchen Bereichen gerade mit dem deutschen System mit Schulen und auch Begutachtungsverfahren, wo man sich schon kennen muss und etabliert sein muss, das es auch oft aufgebrochen wird und die Kommission eigentlich Wert darauf legt, auch frische Namen zu haben. Sei es bei den Begutachtern, jetzt nicht nur die alten Recken zieht.
Das Begutachtungssystem ist auch so, dass wirklich Wissenschaftler oder Industriepartner, also die Akteure selber die Begutachtung als Peer-Review durchführen. Und das ist, habe ich schon oft erlebt, also in den Projekten oft ein Platz für Nachwuchswissenschaftler sich zu etablieren in europäische und internationale Kooperationen reinzukommen. Und was man eben auch oft feststellt als Berater, dass gerade die jungen noch frisch sind und Regeln akzeptieren, sich mit denen auseinandersetzen und nicht sagen, ach ist ja alles schrecklich, ist ja so anders als ich das bisher kenne, sondern deshalb auch eine gute Chance haben, weil die sagen, okay wie sind die Regeln, ich schreibe den Antrag so und stelle jetzt nicht alles in Frage. Und sind dadurch also auch erfolgreich. Und man muss eben noch mal genau diese Rollen unterscheiden, dass der Koordinator dieses ganze Paket auf den Weg bringt und auch sein Team zusammenstellt, der hat natürlich viel Arbeit, aber wenn man als Partner irgendwo mitmacht, hält sich das in Grenzen.
Kommt dann drauf an, wie der Koordinator auch diese Antragsstellung organisiert. Aber oft steuert man da vielleicht seinen Namen da bei, seine Beschreibung, seine Einrichtung. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen Arbeitspakete, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man als Partner ständig zusammenbrechen würde, wenn man mitmacht.
Wer bewertet denn jetzt diese Anträge? Also und vor allem auch, wie viele kommen da auch jedes auf den Tisch? Wie viele Gruppen bewerben sich so insgesamt?
Tausende, ich habe gerade die letzte Zahl bekommen in diesem Jahr.
Tausende, und wie viel kriegen was? Also wie viele Projekte werden bewilligt?
Ja ist auch eine gute Frage, die wir jetzt nochmal bei Förderquoten immer mit Blick auf die einzelnen Programme anschauen müssen. Also es gibt Programme, die sind mit 10% dabei. Es gibt welche, - also 10% Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit – andere sind mit 30% Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit versehen. Und das ist wie so ein Biorhythmus, manchmal fluktuiert das auch über die Laufzeit eines Programmes. Da wo viel Überzeichnung war, sind vielleicht in der nächsten Runde viele verschreckt und sagen, nein mach ich nicht nochmal. Da hat man dann eine Chance. Es ist auch Teil unserer Beratung, zu analysieren, wo sehen wir vielleicht gute Chancen, wenn wir das Programm verfolgen und wo muss man sagen, ihr müsst wirklich damit rechnen, dass die Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit nicht so hoch ist und versucht dann mal euer Glück. Also es variiert.
Das ist schon eine Menge Arbeit. Also man darf das nicht unterschätzen. Man muss sich da ganz schön aufreißen. Ich habe das so ein paar Mal aus der Ferne beobachtet und es ist so immer natürlich so ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit und die Deadline. Also ich denke, da wird sowieso immer alles fünf Minuten vor der Deadline dann, oh Gott hoffentlich funktioniert mein Internet jetzt auch.
Ja gibt es auch Dramen.
Ja aber halt auch diese Abstimmungsproblematiken. Also an der Stelle übt man ja im Prinzip auch schon mal die Kommunikation und insofern ist das vielleicht schon mal ganz hilfreich, da auch ein bisschen durch den Regen marschieren zu müssen. Wer bewertet letztlich? Und was sind so – na gut über die Kriterien haben wir schon ein bisschen gesprochen – aber wie wird ein Antrag bewertet? Also wird von einer Person gelesen? Von mehreren Personen gelesen? Wie viele Gutachten werden dann noch eingeholt dafür? Wie läuft dieser Bewertungsprozess denn ab?
Wenn man jetzt aufs Rahmenprogramm schaut, und wir bleiben nochmal, wenn Sie wollen, bei der Verbundforschung vielleicht als erstes. Weil dieser europäische Forschungsrat arbeitet etwas anders. Aber im Grunde eher noch wissenschaftsnäher. Dann ist es so, dass jetzt im Horizont2020, das ist vielleicht auch eine gute Botschaft, viele zweistufige Verfahren eingeführt wurden. Das heißt in der ersten Stufe schreibt man erst mal einen kleineren Antrag, einen kürzeren und wirft seinen Hut in den Ring. Das hat den Vorteil, dass die Themen erst mal breiter sein können und man wegkommen wollte von den Probleme im letzten Rahmenprogramm, dass oft die Themen, so hieß es, so zugeschnitten waren, dass man eigentlich schon sehen konnte, welches Team dahintersteht und dafür gesorgt hat, dass das Thema so formuliert, ja vielleicht mit dem Modellorganismus und dieser Technik, dass man sehen konnte, da kommt ja nur die Gruppe XY in Frage. Jetzt sind die Themen breiter ausgeschrieben und man bewirbt sich in der ersten Stufe erst mal mit einer Idee, mit 10-16 Seiten.
Und das heißt, man hat in der ersten Stufe erst mal eine Massenbegutachtung zu bewältigen aus Sicht der Kommission. Das heißt es gibt Gutachter, die Anträge bekommen remote, also im Verfahren vor Ort, sich die Anträge anschauen und man dann zu den Ergebnissen kommt, die sagen, welche Anträge werden in die zweite Stufe eingeladen.
War das schon immer ein zweistufiger Prozess?
Nicht in allen Bereichen. Manche haben schon immer so operiert, manche Themenbereiche. Und jetzt ist es so, dass es stärker noch eingesetzt wird auch in der Gesundheitsforschung, in den Biowissenschaften war das so.
Das ist so ein Trend sozusagen?
Ist ein Trend. Ja aber mit der politischen Vorgabe, wir wollen offener sein für Ideen und less prescriptive, also weniger vorschreibend.
Ja. Okay, das heißt man muss überhaupt erst mal so einen Vorantrag machen. So nach dem Motto, wir beschreiben jetzt mal ganz allgemein, wohin wir wollen und die Relevanz und warum muss das beforscht werden etc.
Genau, und das ist unsere Idee.
Man hat aber auch den Vorteil, man muss da jetzt noch nicht so in die Vollen gehen mit irgendwie allen Detailplänen und Reisekosten und pipapo.
Nein noch nicht.
Es geht überhaupt erst mal darum, inhaltlich auch klar zu machen, warum muss das sein? Sodass eben auch eine Bewertungsgruppe dann erst mal sagen kann, naja okay schönes Thema, nächstes Jahr vielleicht. Aber passt jetzt gerade nicht so.
Doch nicht so innovativ oder erfüllt nicht das, was dieses Thema eigentlich erreichen möchte. Und ja dann hat man also die Chance, den Hut in den Ring zu werfen.
Das heißt da fallen auch noch nicht unbedingt alle raus, sondern keine Ahnung wie sich das Feld dann so lichtet, die Hälfte oder so?
Ja, idealerweise, das sind jetzt die Reaktionen auf die Erfahrung der ersten Runde. In einigen Bereichen gab es immer noch zu viele in der zweiten Stufe, so dass dann, Sie kennen das vielleicht aus den Augenwinkeln, diese hundert Seiten oder was geschrieben werden, der ganze Vollantrag immer noch zu viele keine Chance hatten. Und idealerweise versucht man jetzt auch durch Einflussnahme und Feedback zu organisieren, dass es eine Förderwahrscheinlichkeit von 30% in der zweiten Stufe möglich ist. Dass also jeder dritte Antrag durchkommt. Das wäre schon ganz hilfreich. Und wenn wir jetzt über die, also tatsächlich die Intensivbegutachtung sprechen, dann sieht es in der Regel so aus, dass fünf Gutachter auf einen Antrag schauen und sich dann intensiv mit diesem Antrag auseinandersetzen. Schauen, die werden ja dann zu einzelnen Themen eingereicht und dann auch nochmal in Brüssel zusammenkommen, es gibt Konsensusmeetings.
Sind die dann anonymisiert? Also wissen die Gutachter, wen sie da gerade begutachten?
Die wissen das. Das steht auch im Antrag. Die sind aber zu absoluter Vertraulichkeit verpflichtet. Also das ist eigentlich so gängiges Begutachtungsverfahren. Das sie dann als Gutachter dann unterschreiben vorher eine Vertraulichkeitsvereinbarung und sind zu Vertraulichkeit verpflichtet, während dieses ganzen Prozesses.
Okay, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da generell mit so einem Doppelblindtest gearbeitet wird, dass man irgendwie nicht weiß, wer das ist oder weiß nicht, wie sich das vielleicht auch so im Geschlechterverhältnis zusammensetzt das Team, keine Ahnung.
Geschlechter ist auch nochmal ein wichtiges Thema, weil selbst also die Kommission bemüht sich, anders als andere nationale Förderer mehr noch um Gendermainstreaming ist das Wort, Geschlechterneutralität. Das heißt Sie können auch im weitesten Sinne punkten damit, dass sie sagen, in unserem Team, in unserem Konsortium sind Frauen, auch mit Schlüsselpositionen, das geht auch als ein Unterpunkt in die Evaluierung ein, wenn Anträge wirklich in allem Exzellenz und in der Anwendung gleich wären, gleiche Punktzahlen bekommen, dann wäre das auch noch am Ende ein Faktor.
Okay, ich hätte jetzt auch das andere Modell mir vorstellen können.
Ja das ist eine gute Frage.
Das man sagt, man lässt jetzt die Personen sozusagen komplett raus. Weil ist natürlich auch so, wenn neue Leute einen bestimmten Namen haben und so, dann wird das immer gleich anders bewertet. Hätte ich auch mal interessant gefunden.
Ich muss auch sagen, Sie wären geeignet als Berater der Kommission. Denn es gab mal ein Rahmenprogramm. Ich müsste jetzt mal sagen, ich glaube das war das fünfte. Die Regeln ändern sich eben mit jedem Rahmenprogramm, wie Sie sagen. Und immer wird versucht, auch etwas besser zu machen und das ist nicht unbedingt dann wahrgenommen auch als Verbesserung. Damals gab es wirklich die Vorgabe, strikt einzuhalten, alles anonym zu schreiben. Also in dem gesamten 50/60/70 seitigen Antrag durfte keine Identität eines Partners erfahrbar sein. Wenn da also irgendeine Referenz war, die den Gutachtern nahegelegt hat, ich glaube ich vermute wer das ist, dann war der Antrag formal gescheitert.
Aber hat nicht funktioniert?
Ich weiß auch nicht. Es wurde dann in dem Zuge, es besser zu machen, wieder in eine transparente und offene Beschreibung der Partner gegeben. Und man kann sich vorstellen warum, weil man natürlich auch mit einer gewissen Beurteilung der Güte der Partner vielleicht verbindet, dass man mal checken kann, wer steht dahinter.
Ja klar, ich meine wenn etwas natürlich Reputation hat, dann ist das natürlich auch ein Argument, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Aber es gab auch mal den Ansatz.
Okay. Aber zumindest ist so Geschlechtergerechtigkeit da auf jeden Fall ein Thema mittlerweile in den Vergabekriterien und fließt in die Punkte ein. Das wäre nämlich jetzt eben meine nächste Frage gewesen. Also im Prinzip die Gutachter bewerten das mit Punkten? Es gibt da einen gewissen Katalog, wie man diese Punkte anzuwenden hat und dann gibt es sicherlich auch nochmal so einen bestimmten Bereich, der ist so der persönlichen Einschätzung überlassen natürlich. Und jeder Antrag wird fünf mal angeschaut und kriegt dann eine entsprechende Summe oder Durchschnitt. Und das ist dann alleinig entscheidend dafür, ob man hop oder top dabei ist oder nicht in der zweiten Runde?
Dann kommt es darauf an, was die Kollegen gemacht haben. Also was die Konkurrenz gemacht hat. Es gibt Schwellenwerte. Also die Skala ist eben im Normalfall liegt die bei den europäischen Programmen zwischen 1-5, in der man sich bewegt. Die Gutachter vergeben also Punkte von 0 bis 5 und es gibt Schwellenwerte für die wissenschaftliche Exzellenz. Also drei Kriterien, wissenschaftliche Exzellenz, dann der Impact, was bringt ihr Projekt im Hinblick auf das was formuliert wurde an Zielen und wie ist die Durchführung. Also wie ist das Management, wie verbreiten sie die Ergebnisse, wie kommunizieren sie mit der Außenwelt. Und für diese Kriterien gibt es je nach Programm wieder Schwellenwerte, die muss man erst mal übersteigen, damit man überhaupt eine Chance hat, gefördert zu werden. Und wenn sie da eine hohe Punktzahl haben kommt es darauf an, hat die Konkurrenz noch höhere Punkte erreicht? Also wir hatten jetzt gerade in dieser ersten Runde, wo so viel Konkurrenz war in einigen Bereichen, Projekte die wir hatten, also maximal sind 15 Punkte zu erreichen, 3 mal 15 in diesen Kriterien, die hatten 14,5 Punkte und konnten nicht gefördert werden. Wenn man Glück hatte konnte man vielleicht schon mit 12 Punkten punkten oder landen, weil auch die Konkurrenz nicht besser war.
Aber man kriegt diese Punktzahl auch genannt? Also man weiß zumindest danach, wie man da stand?
Ja genau, man bekommt einen Bericht aus dieser Evaluierung. Man muss auch sagen, diese ganze Evaluierung wird begleitet jeweils von unabhängigen Beobachtern. Das sind erfahrene Wissenschaftler oder auch Gutachter aus den Wissenschaftssystemen, die dürfen überall reinschnüffeln. Die können sich diese Begutachtungsrunden anschauen. Die schreiben hinterher einen Bericht und kommentieren auch, wenn ihnen irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten begegnet sind. Also dieses Peer-Review-Verfahren der Kommission ist eigentlich, obwohl man natürlich im Detail an jedem Begutachtungsverfahren kritisieren kann, aber es ist weltweit Spitze, muss man wirklich sagen.
Was die Transparenz betrifft?
Ja und auch das Verfahren an sich. Wie diese Briefings der Gutachter laufen. Sie haben auch als Antragssteller, das ist so ein kleiner Tipp am Rande, Sie können sich mit der Antragstellung orientieren schon an dem Leitfaden, den die Gutachter auch haben. Das heißt Sie wissen genau als Antragsteller, wonach werde ich begutachtet. Das kann man auch nicht über jedes Förderprogramm sagen, was man so national sieht.
Und diese Regeln gelten jetzt sowohl für die erste als auch für die zweite Runde oder ist das jetzt wirklich nur dieser erste Durchlauf?
Ja wir könnten natürlich nochmal ins Detail gehen. In diesem ersten Durchlauf werden viele Sachen, durch dieses Massenverfahren, auch vor Ort gemacht. Das heißt die Gutachter bekommen aus einem System die Anträge elektronisch und treffen sich nicht alle in Brüssel, weil das logistisch gar nicht zu lösen wäre. Aber in der zweiten Stufe gibt es dann diese Treffen, Konsensusmeetings im Normalfall. Und die Gutachter sprechen auch nochmal darum, und versuchen ihre Noten abzugleichen und dann einen Konsens zu finden für die Endnote. Und dann können Sie sich vorstellen, wenn wir jetzt wieder schauen auf diese Marie-Curie-Actions, dieses Massenprogramm und auch andere kleinere schlankere Verfahren, da laufen die Begutachtungsverfahren etwas anders. Aber im Grunde ist es so, es gibt eine Gutachterdatenbank, da kann sich auch jeder Wissenschaftler eintragen. Da kann ich auch nur jeden ermuntern, der irgendwie schon eine gewisse Vita vorzuweisen hat oder Publikationen.
Also um auch selber mal Gutachter zu werden sozusagen.
Absolut.
Das ist natürlich auch ganz hilfreich, denn da sieht man eine ganze Menge Anträge mal.
Das ist das perfekte Antragstraining für jemanden. Man bekommt das auch bezahlt. Was jetzt für die Topwissenschaftler nicht mehr so das Zugpferd ist, die sowieso viel in Gremien sitzen. Aber für einen aufstrebenden Nachwuchswissenschaftler, der schon eine interessante Publikationsliste hat, der kann sich vor Ort auch nochmal beraten lassen von uns oder von den EU-Referenden, wie man Buzzwords auch in sein Profil in der Gutachterdatenbank gibt, um eine Chance zu haben, gezogen zu werden. Klassischerweise Frauen, jetzt alles was mit Technologietransfer, mit Kooperation, Innovation zu tun hat, würde wichtig sein. Ja wenn man da gezogen wird kriegt man das bezahlt und kann absolut gutes Antragstraining bekommen. Und lernt die Kommission kennen. Das ist auch nochmal so ein Punkt, dass man dadurch dass man dort in der Begutachtung auf den trifft, der für dieses Thema in der Kommission zuständig ist, der auch die Arbeitsprogramme formuliert, also die Themen für die kommenden Ausschreibungen, ist das auch ein super Weg, um in Kontakt mit der Kommission zu kommen.
Wenn man sich da hervortut als guter Gutachter auffällig wird und sagt gibt neutrale gute Kommentare, die Deutschen sind ja da nicht unbedingt verschrien für schlechte Leistungen, hat man natürlich auch mal die Chance konsultiert zu werden. Das passiert auch oft, dass die dann mal sagen, hier wir haben gemerkt, Sie kennen sich in diesem Themengebiet aus, wir schreiben gerade an den neuen Themen.
Formell, was meinen Sie denn?
Wohin soll es gehen?
Ist das dann bei dem europäischen Forschungsrat mit den anderen? Was hatten wir vorhin für einen Begriff gewählt? Also Verbundforschung war der Name für diese …
Für diese Top-Down-Themen.
Für die Kommission. Und wie würde man dann den anderen Bereich nennen des Forschungsrates?
Forschungsrat ist die Bottom-Up-Forschung, die Exzellenzförderung. Bottom-Up ist jetzt auch themenoffen.
Schlüsseltechnologien.
Nein, Schlüssel auch nicht, die sind schon wieder dann.
Auch nochmal was anderes, okay gut Entschuldigung.
Industrienah.
Und arbeiten die dann auch ähnlich mit demselben Gutachterbewertungsmodell oder?
Da geht es rein um Exzellenz und auch um die Lebensleistung eines Wissenschaftlers. Ja also um die Vita und da geht es natürlich nicht um Abgleich, was haben wir vorgegeben und was ist die Antwort darauf dieses Teams.  Und da spielen dann natürlich auch diese Kontakte eine geringere Rolle, weil das sind neutrale Verfahren, die sich, wo niemand sagen muss, sind da jetzt wirklich die Ziele erfüllt und wo kommen die Ziele überhaupt her. Sondern das ist ihre eigene Idee und man schaut nur, ist diese Idee innovativ und bringt uns als Grundlagenforschung in neue Dimensionen.
Gibt es denn eine, ich meine wenn jetzt diese Projekte bewilligt wurden und finanziert wurden, gibt es denn eine Evaluation der Ergebnisse? Also gibt es auch in irgendeiner Form eine Nacharbeit, wo man sehen kann, da ist jetzt auch wirklich was bei .. also irgendwas wird ja bei herausgekommen sein. Aber wird das in irgendeiner Form nochmal quantifiziert, bewertet, begutachtet?
Ja, das ist auch eine gute Frage, gerade aus Sicht der Steuerzahler oder auch des Parlamentes war das auch ein großer Punkt.
Weil ich meine, ist ja immer schwierig, Forschung zu bewerten. Und vor allem wann macht man das?
Und woran misst man das? Gerade weil noch nicht marktnahe Forschung, wo man sagt, am Ende zählt dann nur der Dollar. Was die Projekte liefern müssen, schon mit der Antragstellung, sind Kriterien, was herauskommen soll. Und ich sagte schon, dass die Projektbegleitung auch oft durch ein Gremium passiert, dass sich dieses Projekt gibt oder was von der Kommission bestellt wird und man schaut am Ende in den klassischen Kategorien, was ist publiziert worden, sind Patente angemeldet worden, wenn es jetzt in den marktnäheren Bereich geht? Haben Sie in dem Antrag auch gesagt, wir wollen bis zum Ende des Projektes einen Prototyp entwickeln. Oder in dem Bereich, wo es vielleicht um Beratung geht, Politikberatung, ist eine neue Grundlage für Richtlinien erstellt worden oder irgendwelche Regularien sind beeinflusst worden und dann würde man am Ende schon schauen, ist das passiert? Und bekommen Sie das Geld am Ende auch dafür, geleistet zu haben, was Sie versprochen haben.
Die Frage ist dann, wie ist der Durchgriff, wenn das erfüllt ist oder mehr oder weniger erfüllt ist und was passiert, wenn es Zweifel gibt, wer hat da noch Interesse dran, nachzuschauen, was geliefert wird. Ich glaube da sind auch auf der nationalen Ebene die Kontrollmechanismen greifen da nicht so stark.
Also es gibt zumindest jetzt keinen offiziellen Prozess, der jetzt grundsätzlich eine Postprojektevaluation macht oder doch?
Die Kommission arbeitet dran. Das ist so dieser Schritt, den ich beschrieben habe, der sukzessive einsetzen wird, dass die Generaldirektion Forschung, also das Ministerium sich mehr in den Bereich auch der Politikgestaltung geben wird. Dass da jetzt eine ganze Abteilung dran arbeitet, zu verstehen, wie kann man denn dieses exposte Evaluieren überhaupt auf den Weg bringen. Das ganze Rahmenprogramm musste auch, also da gibt es Indikatoren, um zu sagen, wie wird dieses Rahmenprogramm am Ende mal bewertet. Da gibt es Indikatoren eben auch geschaffene Stellen, Patentanmeldungen, Kriterien, an denen das gesamte Rahmenprogramm gewertet wird. Aber ist die Frage jetzt auf der Projektebene, wenn Ihnen abgenommen wird am Ende von dem Projectofficer, dass das Projekt gut erfüllt wurde, dass schaut da niemand mehr nach und sagt, Sie müssen Geld abgeben, weil vielleicht dann doch nicht so viel passiert ist, wie ursprünglich.
Ja mir ging es nicht so sehr um so eine Rückerstattung oder so was, das fände ich auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen frech. Aber aus Sicht der Kommission bzw. Auch des Forschungsrates ist es ja sicherlich auch von Interesse in irgendeiner Form eine Statistik aufbauen zu können, wie erfolgreich waren denn unsere Forschungsförderungsmaßnahmen. Also gibt es überhaupt eine Möglichkeit, das zu quantifizieren? Das ist natürlich erst mal eine ganz grundsätzliche Frage und irgendeiner Form will man da ja dann vielleicht auch mal bewerten, auch um zukünftige Rahmenprogramme neu abzustecken, muss man das ja auch irgendwie bewerten können.
Absolut. Also die …
Ist aber ein ungelöstes Problem noch oder?
Wie gesagt, diese Indikatoren stehen fest, das sind diese Dinge wie Patente, Innovationsfähigkeit erhöht zu haben, die werden dann auch gegenüber dem Parlament und den Mitgliedsstaaten abgefragt und der ganze Bereich der wird noch mehr Fahrt aufnehmen, denke ich, jetzt mit dieser stärkeren Politikorientierung der Generaldirektion Forschung und Innovation. Aber die große Frage war jetzt auch in der .. wir haben diesen Prozess ja gerade erlebt in der Vorbereitung von Horizon2020, als es auch darum ging, gegen den Trend mehr in Forschung und Innovation zu investieren. Also es war eigentlich ein großer Erfolg, auch wenn es hätte mehr sein können, dass das Rahmenprogramm nicht abgeschmolzen ist.
Also gegen den Trend allgemeiner Investitionen in alles mögliche.
Genau und deren EU-Haushalt auch stagnieren zu lassen bzw. Auch zurückzuschrauben. Aber ich könnte ja auch mal zurückfragen an Sie als Bürger, was wären denn für Sie Indikatoren, zu sagen, so ein Programm war erfolgreich?
Tja schwierig. Ich meine, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe die Frage jetzt zwar gestellt, aber meine Erwartung wäre eher gewesen, dass man sagt, das lässt sich alles so schwer messen, weil ja nun gerade Grundlagenforschung, da weiß man irgendwie vielleicht erst in 10 oder 20 Jahren, dass irgendwo ein Durchbruch dann tatsächlich irgendwas nach sich gezogen hat. Und manches mag irgendwie relevant erscheinen, zeigt sich aber später als der größte Sprung der Geschichte. Und anderes mag gerade irgendwie zwar Buzzword compliant sein, aber hat halt am Ende nicht viel gebracht. Und auch die Rückwirkung jetzt in unmittelbare industrielle Wachstumsmärkte, ich meine, wer will das dann am Ende noch ausrechnen, was da jetzt wirklich die Faktoren waren oder wo nicht irgendwie Zweitforschung, Parallelforschung, Ergebnisse aus anderen Ländern usw. Auch noch mit reingespielt haben. Also ich stelle mir das schwierig vor, aber das war jetzt einfach nur mal so meine Frage.
Es ist schwierig. Und das Parlament würde sich eben mit dieser Erklärung nicht zufrieden geben. Der Forschungsrat, das haben Sie schon richtig getroffen, der ist fast außen vor, weil Grundlagenforschung diese Stimme ist stark eingebracht, zu sagen, Grundlagenforschung ist perse wichtig, um überhaupt uns zu befruchten mit den Grundlagen für jede Art von Innovation. Aber danach wird es dann schon schwierig.
Jetzt haben wir viel von Innovation und Technologie gesprochen etc. Und das ist natürlich auch immer das, was man gerade bei Forschung so macht. Jetzt klang ja vorhin schon mal an, Sozial- und Geisteswissenschaften haben so ein bisschen nochmal so einen eigenen Bereich, aber sind ja auch Teil der Verbundforschung, der vorgegebenen Themen der Kommission. Welche Rolle spielen diese nichttechnischen Disziplinen in dem gesamten Förderungsprogramm?
Ja Sie treffen da nochmal einen großen Punkt, der auch in der ganzen Diskussion um Horizon2020 und der auch jetzt in der Beratung und Durchführung eine wichtige Rolle spielt, scheinbar sind die Sozial- und Geisteswissenschaften zurückgestutzt worden jetzt in Horizon2020, weil sie kein ganz großes eigenes Programm mehr haben. Es ist immerhin erreicht worden auch durch eine große Aktivität dieser Stakeholder, also dieser Interessengruppe, dass es immerhin noch eine Challenge gibt, die heißt Societys und dort finden sich vor allen Dingen sozialwissenschaftliche wirtschaftswissenschaftliche Themen wieder. Wichtig ist jetzt für einen Wissenschaftler oder die Kommission würde so antworten, dass es eigentlich mehr Geld für zumindest für Sozial- und Wirtschaftswissenschaftler, Geisteswissenschaftler da muss man differenzierter schauen als jemals vorher. Für alle steht dieser europäische Forschungsrat offen. European Research council, weil da eben themenoffen Grundlagenforschung fördert für alle. Also da wäre die erste Adresse.
Und dann durchziehen aber all diese Challenges und eigentlich jedes Projekt kann darauf hin abgeklopft werden, ob nicht irgendwo auch der Platz ist für soziale und zumindest wirtschaftswissenschaftliche Aspekte, die in so einem Projekt adressiert werden. Also zum Beispiel nehmen wir mal den Bereich Nanoprojekt als Schlüsseltechnologie, Nanopartikelentwicklung für einen Sensor. Da würde wahrscheinlich könnte ich mir vorstellen ein Thema so heißen, dass man begleitend im Blick behalten soll, dass die Entwicklung, die dann mal herauskommt, auch von der Bevölkerung akzeptiert wird und aufgenommen wird. Also spielen oft ethische Fragen eine Rolle. Es müssen aber auch Businesspläne erstellt werden oder Begleitstudien, wo also ein großer Platz ist für Sozial- und Geisteswissenschaftler, die wir speziell auch gerne motivieren würden, sich nicht abschrecken zu lassen von dieser scheinbar nur innovationsorientierten und technologieorientierten, diesem Gewand von Horizon, sondern im Detail mal reinzuschauen in die Themen, ob man nicht doch für sein Thema einen Platz findet.
Ja da hatten wir ja, hier lohnt auch mal ein Querverweis, bei Forschergeist schon ein interessantes Gespräch über autonomen Verkehr und die damit verbundenen ethisch-moralischen Fragen, rechtlich etc. Also überhaupt alle Fragen, was hindert eine Technologie daran, potenziell unter Umständen aufgenommen oder übernommen zu werden, überhaupt erfolgreich zu sein, in eben nicht technischer Hinsicht. Also auch in nicht technischer Hinsicht, darüber haben wir uns unterhalten, daran erinnert mich das jetzt gerade. Insofern kann man ja sagen, auch diese Disziplinen sollten ja in diesem Förderprogramm ihren Platz haben. Haben sie den auch?
Die haben den, also die Disziplinen, über die wir jetzt gerade sprechen, die haben ihren Platz und können über den ERC da, also wer Topforschung macht, der hat sowieso einen Platz. Wer in diese Themenverbünde reingeht, der muss eben genau schauen und sich wahrscheinlich mehr beraten lassen als in der Vergangenheit, wo das einfach so aufschien. Was eine schwierige Frage ist, ist die Frage inwieweit auch die Geisteswissenschaften Themen platzieren können, die für die kulturelle Identität oder genuin europäische Themen, die sie selber aus eigenem Antrieb und nicht so als mit dem Vorwurf, wir sind ja nur die Begleitforschung in technologielastigen Projekten, inwieweit die gut bestückt sind. Das wäre wohl eine Frage, die dieses Rahmenprogramm nicht ganz zufriedenstellend beantworten kann.
Aber es gab solche Projekte schon?
Es gab die schon ja.
Haben Sie da ein Beispiel parat so, was da so?
Es gab, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so passt, aber es gab zum Beispiel Projekte, die so eine Art Pisastudie europäisch Abgleich, wie ein Schüler ausgetauscht. Was bedeutet Glück im europäischen Kontext? Was sind die Herausforderungen, mit Migration umzugehen?
Naja aber das sind ja alles genauso auch Faktoren, die auf die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung Europas beeinflussen.
Ja. Und die an dieser Schnittstelle eben auch wirtschaftlich relevant zu sein auch förderwürdig werden. Also Geld ist vorhanden. Da ist gerade in diesem Bereich eben die Frage auch der geschickten Themenplatzierung. Es gibt auf jeden Fall mehr Ideen aus diesen sozial- und geisteswissenschaftlichen Bereich als es Themen anhand der absehbaren Budgets Eingang finden werden in die Ausschreibung. Deshalb ist die Frage, wer setzt sich durch?
Noch keine 100%ige Genehmigungsquote sozusagen?
Ja da fehlt noch ein Programm, was dann größer Verbünde fördert im offenen Bereich.
Ja, jetzt haben wir alles eigentlich ganz gut zusammengefegt die Themenlandschaft, habe ich so den Eindruck. Vielleicht nochmal so zum Abschluss zur Arbeit von KOWI selbst. Wie bekannt ist Ihr Büro und die Arbeit so im Wissenschaftsbereich? Haben Sie da den Eindruck, dass sich das schon gut rumgesprochen hat? Gibt es da Verbesserungspotenzial?
Ich denke, ... dass es ein Verbesserungspotenzial nach oben gibt, das immer. Es wäre anmaßend, zu sagen, dass wir flächendeckend bekannt sind. Wir sind sicher bekannt an der Stelle dieser EU-Experten, mit denen wir vor allen Dingen arbeiten in den Einrichtungen. Schon alleine bei den Hochschulleitungen muss man sagen, die Fluktuation, die Rotation ist so hoch, dass es eigentlich für uns eine Daueraufgabe ist.
Die Fluktuation jetzt in diesen Kontaktstellen?
Nicht bei uns, sondern in den Positionen. Also wir arbeiten mit strategischen Formaten auch mit den Hochschulleitungen zusammen, um Europa in der Gesamtstrategie einer Einrichtung zu platzieren. Also nicht nur in den Hochschulen, aber primär in den Hochschulen, wo das ja eine riesige Einrichtung ist, die Prioritäten setzt und auch nationale Exzellenzaufstellungen in Einklang bringt mit dem, was international oder europäisch wichtig ist. Und diese Positionen, Präsidien, die wechseln ja auch. Personen kommen wieder dazu, das heißt dass eigentlich eine stetige Aufgabe, dort am Ball zu bleiben. Wir arbeiten mit den Länderministerien zusammen, wir sind über die DFG finanziert und Hochschulen sind Ländersache, arbeiten also auch mit den Länderministerien zusammen, mit den Referenden dort, die für Forschung und Wissenschaft zuständig sind, die kennen uns. Also ich denke, wir sind bekannt. Auf der Ebene der Wissenschaftler würde ich sagen, ist die Durchdringung auch durch die Fluktuation sicher so, dass man da nie genug tun kann, zu sagen, wir haben einen Newsletter, uns gibt es, kommt auf uns zu.
Ja aber ich meine, das ist ja auch ein Grund, warum wir jetzt dieses Gespräch hier geführt haben. Also wenn man quasi darüber nachdenkt, auf europäischer Ebene förderungswürdig vielleicht zu sein, dann gibt es auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge zu beachten und viele Fehler könnten vielleicht von Vornherein vermieden werden. Wenn man mal jemanden fragt, der da was davon versteht und sich da ohnehin regelmäßig mit beschäftigt. Und das gilt eben für die Kooperationsstelle heißt es ja oder?
Jetzt neu. Auf keinen Fall koordiniert. Aber Kooperation, das drückt auch eigentlich den Geist unserer Einrichtung aus.
Also ist das jetzt ein neuer Name, der jetzt? Wurde das umbenannt?
Seit mehreren Jahren.
Früher hieß es mal anders, aber das schweigen wir jetzt tot.
Das war diese Koordination, wo ich meinte, dass die KOWI als einzige Vertretung sämtliche Stimmen der deutschen Wissenschaft koordiniert, in Brüssel transportieren konnten.
Also dahingehend auch umbenannt.
Ja und wenn man jetzt so diverse Stimmen, wie Max-Planck und Fraunhofer sich vorstellt, da sind dann durchaus Unterschiede in der Aufstellung der forschungspolitischen.
Von der Koordination zur Kooperation. Ja Frau Eggert vielen Dank.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Das war auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Ritt hier durch die europäische Förderungswelt und ich denke, hier sollte für den ein oder anderen Wissenschaftler und auch vielleicht Leute, die die Aufgabe auch an den Universitäten haben, die Wissenschaftler entsprechend zu unterstützen, einiges dabei gewesen sein. Und ich bedanke mich für das Gespräch und bedanke mich wie immer natürlich auch fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist vom Stifterverband. Ich wünsche alle noch einen schönen Tag und wir hören uns dann bald bei der nächsten Ausgabe von Forschergeist.